day two of the u.s senior championship
where the legends come to play the
former kings of american chess returned
to do battle
in the furious hunt for the 2020 title
co-leader igor novikov played solidly
and drew all three games
and that allowed joel benjamin to
leapfrog him with two wins
and stand alone atop his long time
rivals
the gladiators are back in the ring to
decide who will be crowned the champion
the final day of exciting action coming
up next
hello everyone and welcome to the 2020
u.s senior championship i'm jennifer
shahidi and i'm here with
maurice ashley and yasser sarawan as
we crown a champion today
hello jennifer hello everyone and thank
you for joining us
and sharing your day with with us for
the senior championship
uh today we as jennifer said we will be
crowning a champion the first day was
quite spotty i felt
but the second day of vast improvement
by the players and the quality of their
games as they've adjusted to this time
control
in particular i thought joel benjamin
joel benjamin
played some excellent endings so maurice
i'm looking forward to a fight a great
finals day
it's really wonderful to see the players
just settle in
and groove to this new time control we
know they have the elegant moves in them
the fine technique the vicious attacking
style
we know they can get it done but at
first they look a little wobbly
now they look like they're ready two
days under their belts
this should be some good stuff
let's take a look the standings gym well
here they are guys we've got
two players who have set themselves
apart here
as grand master joel benjamin has four
and a half points
he's a half point behind ahead of the
leader
ahead of the runner-up igor novokov but
look at everybody else guys there's that
big
gap a full point gap that really means
that for wolf gervais and kaidana
i think they almost have to win all
their games to have a good chance at
first and even then they might only get
a playoff
exactly somebody's got to slip up joel
and igor and what is the format for
this final day of play jen we've got
three
more games of game 25 with a five second
increment that is our time control
love it it's lots of rich ideas in the
opening and then lots of wild time
scrambles
and we have a thousand dollar prize fund
uh very generous price on including 12k
for first
there will be a tie break if there are
two players at the top of the
leaderboard
after nine rounds and
and this is how it's going to look guys
we know this though because just a
couple days ago
we were calling a playoff at the us
junior championship
this will be two-game rap and match game
10 and with a two second increment
and then if it goes to armageddon we
will answer the question everybody has
been wondering
will the seniors have their pre-move
turned on
we can only hope chet you would yes
get in there with some blitz action i
know i would love to
but we have grandmas for maurice ashley
to dig a little deeper into how
the seniors got here well everybody has
their own road you know their own lane
and got here different ways for sure be
a miracle if they all play the exact
same way
for six rounds but these points they
tell
the tale and let's dig a little bit
deeper
first of all starting with dimitri
gravitch
who's tied for third place you see how
he started off quietly with two draws
and then a loss in round three he might
have walked out said you know had a bad
day
then he came back immediately with a win
in round four
only to draw yet again so that gives him
a solid
three points now very similarly though
not exactly the same
was gregory kaidanov he started off the
tournament
right away with a victory he won
and then he drew his next two games game
so he must have felt like okay that was
a solid day
except bang right away in round four he
lost the game
and then could only draw yet again so
that's how
he got to his 50 however patrick wolf
a completely different route matter of
fact
he mentioned to us yesterday that he may
not have remembered how to draw
in chess at all lost his first game
came back with a win bang bang only to
then get hit
punch to the face twice including a real
miniature
against the lowest rated player in the
competition shelby gets
thankfully for him he was able to win in
round six and even his score
we'll see whether or not he continues
his belligerent ways
in this event now another player though
who is the only player in the whole
field
not to have lost the game was igor
novikov he's in second place a point
clear
of the players in third drew his first
game then had a marvelous back-to-back
day
on day one with wins in round two and
round three
but played very cautiously it looks like
very solid chess in four five and six
and those games
really represented him not trying that
hard it looks like
very solid player so far but it's got
him in second place
clear of those players below him but one
player
who's saying uh-uh that's not gonna get
it done it's joel benjamin
he started with two wins in a draw the
same as novakov
and then he lost and actually slipped
out of first for a moment
but then boom hit and another punch one
two got him to his position now he's in
clear first
with four and a half we'll see if he can
keep up his winning ways but guys
yum yum for the first round today
we'll have the two leaders first and
second playing off against each other i
think if joe wins this game just
sign his ticket sign the name on the
check right away if he wins right now
this could be the whole event he could
seal the deal
with another victory and of course he
still had to play a few more games
but i think a win now he's in he's going
to be first
i would agree but i think that you know
igor has been so
solid so far and joel a lot of these
wins have come with the white pieces
especially his
particularly convincing ones so this is
a tough order
for him but he has been his improving
his play as
um i thought it was so funny when you
said vast improvement
and i misheard it as fast
and i was like it as well
because you know we're playing a lot
faster as
we see of course i mean all eyes are
going to be on that igor joel game but
if it dries out we also have plenty of
other entertainment
got to keep on the our eyes on all the
three-pointers to see
if they can run the table today and what
are they playing for jet
fifty thousand dollars including that
first prize of twelve
thousand which by the way will not be
shared in case of a play off the title
and the full 12k will go to the winner
eight thousand dollars for second place
nice price for the big but yes i i think
they
are playing better and they are playing
faster keep in mind that joel benjamin
leading the competition
he had a couple of games where only
after like 20 moves both players
had like less than a minute on their
clock so they were suddenly playing
blitz you know very early so we'll keep
an
eye on this very crucial game um
with uh between our two leaders
wow my pick looks pretty good right now
guys it does
at the top of the leaderboard and yeah
your
your picks are gonna have to really um
sweep the floor today
in order i'm not even hoping for my page
there's no way shabala comes back that
was this one var and i will just have to
sit this one out
and and uh for you guys this will just
be a prayer
to try to see if gregory can actually
catch joel
i point a half down i doubt it
i'm looking for a hell near here guys
but gregory we'll start
is what you're looking for because it's
really not even in gregory's hands
yeah well joel also the thing i like
about joel
here is not only that he has a half
point more but if he survives this game
against novikov we mentioned it
yesterday last round
first shelby getz who's already declared
that he's going to play 1a3
i mean that might be decent as a
surprise but against joel who has plenty
of time to think about
the psychology what he might need i mean
he's just gonna be thrilled with that
outcome
and i wouldn't even be that surprised if
i saw him play e5 actually like a three
five and we go into that reverse candy
that we looked at yesterday
exactly and for igor novikov
igor again as you highlighted uh maurice
been playing very solidly and he's uh
undefeated but he's also been offering
draws i would say
from uh positions of strength
uh so nobody's really put
any i want to say real pressure on igor
igor with the white pieces against joel
if
igor could win this game and they are
off 1d4
well i mean that's that that will
catapult him
to first place
igor is a type of guy he's solid he's
not trying to play spectacular
wild i should say spec speculative
chesses we see a6 make an early
entrance onto the board he's not about
that he's about playing solidly and
beating you with
nice technique solid play now that he
can't mate you want to stick if you play
badly
but he will not
take any major chances a classically
grounded player
if there is one and joel will just have
to keep playing correct chess if he's
going to make it
against his player we see igor is not
surprised by the a6 move at all
yeah um it's a move that really has been
fashioned
by world champion magnus carlson as i
don't
really know where he got it when he
added it to his repertoire but i've seen
a number of times
where he's essayed this move not a big
fan
although i like the queen's gambit
declined
full stop it often requires that the
bishop
place itself on e6 as we're seeing but
if you look at that placement of the
bishop
it's not that wonderful really it would
be much happier say
on g4 so i do anticipate that that
bishop will be moving
again and it's it's very often that
white will also include
moves like h2h3 as well as queen c2
just waiting for black to declare
his intentions of castling short
you see bishop d6 by joel let's just
take a quick gander around
the boards as we'll stop in and look at
over alex yermalinski's shoulder as he's
playing against patrick wolfe and
i wanted to say that i was i was trying
to figure out
is is there something wrong with my
transmission what is this
how is this even possible
the first few moves of a game that we're
seeing this position
has this ever been seen i really want to
know
well this this move order is a move
order i used as white
opening within english to try to
transpose into a king's
indian defense and nobody ever played e7
e5 against me i know
it's a move but knight takes e5
this follow-up i don't know i'm more
familiar with queen
e7 and vark and uh
varusian can give us some pointers on
what the latest and greatest in theory
is
after castles night back okay
um this must be all part of patrick's
homework
rookie eight putting pressure on this
pawn now you would think that uh
d2 d3 is the obvious move here bishop d3
was
your most choice as he's preparing to
get his king out of dodge
and then suddenly be five
that just smells what
i don't know where patrick is is he in
california somewhere but he is
you can just smell this from all the way
across the country
wildfire preparation this is some some
serious home brew and as you said
wildfires the california wildfires on
the board
already upon down he sacks another one
with this move b5 daring the move c
takes b5 maybe d5 will be the response
unquestionably d5 will be the response
it's got to be the reason why he's
playing like this
a d5 threatening to fork the pieces you
can't un-pin
wow that's all i can say about this
position
crazy and guillermo said i don't want
any
parts of this sacrifice my king's
getting out of dodge
i'm leaving thank you very much not even
bothering to test
the critical moves and patrick said okay
i'll just get my pawn back
after this capture although it's not
that obvious now that i look at it
there's a tactic brewing if you take on
e4
there's a knight takes and then a bishop
f7 in the back end
and there's even a bishop d5 waiting for
you so what's the deal here
what maybe it takes first right oh is he
going to play d5
himself because five right
bishop d5 does win and here we go
i want to see the next move is it going
to be d5
no he took okay
what's what's going on knight takes e4
d7 d5 after knight takes e4
why was rookie so rookie for there was
bishop d5 right bishop d5
definitely was without but
but i guess it's got to be d5
yeah i was seeing a ghost of bishop f7
in that position but the
g the d pawn hasn't moved yet but d5
but here the funny thing about this
position is it should be
you're gonna be down a pawn in this line
right you win your piece
back but you're gonna be down
at least a single pawn but he's clearly
prepared this and said this is actually
good for me
i i can only say wow i can only say wow
there is no way do you think he could
have predicted that
yerma would play after bishop g7 in the
king's alien the move e4
this move order oh i guess e4 prevents
the
prevents the the grunfeld the grunfeld
yeah
but uh the bishop d3 followed by b5
that's
that that is a a real uh surprise no
question about it
and i'm just curious here knight takes
now
you don't have to play knight takes you
could play a very funny looking move
queen b3 asking a very salient question
but i think knight d6
tickling the bishop is a is a
is a fine enough resource
it just feels like there ought to be
some way of punishing
black's play but knight takes
pardon me d5 i don't quite see it here
bishop b5 there is rook takes e4 in that
position
and this is the position that you're
most doing over
let him work it out and we'll take a
look at the game between
shelby and gregory kaidana gregory's
was my pick coming into the tournament
he started well enough
that he gave me an enthusiastic start
but it hasn't been good since and a2 a3
mr entertainment shelby getz opening up
with his favorite counter-attacking
opening a3 knight f6
and yeah shelby loves this
um what do we call it a reverse chikorin
how would you approach this if somebody
played a3 against you yes or maurice
like
obviously you're looking for an opening
that
you know where a3 is not a useful move
so
how would you go about deciding e7b6
i i like i've always liked the queen
side fianchettos i've been a big fan of
the hedgehog
and even the bent larson
nimzo b2b3 is move one
and after b7 b6 there is no system
i know where the a2 a3 move is
useful against b7 b6 if you transpose
into a hedgehog
or if you play e4 this is not
a useful move at all so
i like that suggestion and i like how
you also were ready for it i would play
e5
because if my opponent plays d4 i agree
with maurice that like
the lines i'm worried about in the
scandinavian are the ones where you get
to like castle queenside and try to like
you know get some kind of quick maiden
and i think that a3 would actually be a
liability because it's a little bit of a
weakness there
in your queen size structure um but yeah
and also it seems like it's fun to play
this scandinavian with colors reversed
because now all you need is equality
right yeah right and in this
in this variation of the scandinavian
you can play the portuguese gambit with
knight
uh f3 in reverse because there's no
[ __ ]
you just want to get gets his game on
the board while you guys talk about it
now
now we do have it on the on the screen
sorry what about you maurice what would
you play against the super challenging
a3 was this part of your grand master
preparation
with gregory i want to tell you a funny
story okay
uh actually this move
i had the same conception that
shelby had many years ago as a
master level player i argued you know it
seems so logical why
why not just play a move that doesn't
harm your position but gives you a move
and you get to play black
and so i tried it and the person who
made me stop doing it was one oddly
enough here goes the funny part of the
story
patrick wolf patrick
patrick was playing blitz against
patrick i played a3
and he looked at me and he laughed he
said
what is that and he played g6 and of
course he was a better player at the
time
as well and he just punished me and just
like crushed me i was like
okay i guess a3 is not that good i left
it alone
it's funny that gets he didn't get to
play a3 against patrick but it's funny
that gets
beat patrick this tournament not with a3
granted
but still say yeah maurice you had a
little bit too respect too much respect
for your opponent and i was higher rated
than gets at the time or just about
rated his level actually at the time as
well when i was experimenting with this
move
but i think that there are many replies
to the move i think your reply is
correct
uh is good yes i think g6 makes a lot of
sense because
the bishop goes to g7 and you're playing
modern usually terrified of people
taking over space against you
a3 is not going to be one of those
you're going to equalize with ease
however white plays i do remember a game
from uh by grand master duncan settles
duncan
uh up north vancouver bc uh grand master
and he had a game that went a3
uh g6 bishop um
bishop g7 rook a2 no what was the second
move you didn't say the second but you
said a6
g6 you didn't tell us the second mode b4
right
b4 okay b4 uh bishop g7
rook a2 that was like deep thoughts
white prepares to challenge the theater
bishop very very nice
um let's get to the game because the
game was actually very interesting
uh right up to this moment uh
again it's kind of like one of these
reverse chagoran kind of games
after knight c6 bishop g5
instead of playing bishop d7 and maybe
provoking bishop takes pawn takes again
into goran style where white has
this extra a2 a3 move i'm not sure
sure how useful it is um gregory played
bishop e7 and i
don't feel that that is necessarily the
most testing of white setup
takes takes takes takes queen c5
queen b6 queen takes b6
hoping to play knight takes d5 uh-uh
we've got an intermezzo bishop come
bishop takes with check
and the players have found themselves in
this well i guess it's a middle game
position still
but a kind of end game uh with
all kinds of weird looking pawns
bishop f5 strikes me as a decent
move i'm sure there are many other moves
big development big development in our
main game
we need to look at that one as novikov
played a
really slick move and i don't think
benjamin responded to it the best way
on move nine after bishop to d6
novikov played this retreating move it's
a great pin it looks like
benjamin's not testing him he decides to
play this very curious move bishop f4
and benjamin said wait that can't be
right let me take on f4
and after taking pawn takes he realized
wait a minute there's a threat of
f5 so let me move my bishop to g4 but
that opened up the opportunity for
queen to e2 with check
and question mark what are you going to
do you can't bring your bishop back
because of f5
put your queen in the way then there's
an easy continuation for white
trade off on e7 and play knight to e5
and white's got initiative with the king
stuck the bishop still in a weird
situation
as pawns are threatening to attack it
and trap it
benjamin couldn't play like this this
just looks too good for white
and so he had to play the compromising
king
f8 sign me up for that sequence
if i get to play bishop f4 and get this
position on the board i
got to like white here
absolutely white looks great and white
now has a pleasant choice of
how to castle i mean we could castle
queen side
and try to you know consider playing h3
g4 just rolling all the pawns at you
if we're in a feisty mood or we could be
better if we castle king side too
which way we do though yes
um i'm not sure really
uh i think it it it depends if
um how quickly g7 g6 it's
it's like one of those things again i'm
a queen's gambit
the kind player myself so i have a
certain
sympathy empathy for black's position
um but uh i'm expecting something like
okay let's say just uh as a move uh if i
play queen e3 right
uh threatening knight e5 i can imagine
that takes takes
uh check and the tables could get turned
right in the sense that if i put my
queen in the way now
there's nothing nothing there and if i
put a piece in the way
i'm not really happy either so it
doesn't seem to me like i have the move
queen e3
which precipitates the question that you
asked jen where do i put my king
assuming i put my king on the king's
side
then well after g7 g6 castles by hand
i don't think black has that many
worries
so let's say the most h3
let's i don't understand you play
castles i want to cast so you say he
doesn't have worries i'm getting excited
i want to play h3 he actually played no
no i wanted to castle
and see your g6 and then play h3 he
played h3 to start you play h3 right
away i'm a little afraid of a check on
the line
but let's just follow this line h3 your
plan is and after queen takes
and so c6 yeah so c6 so
f5 doesn't concern you here or
or maybe i don't even need f5 but
okay so this position so this kind of
setup you're not worried about is what
you're saying
not not especially i think well i mean
the structure is solid it really does
come down to maurice's
has black compromised his king
he did play the move king f8 he's
castling by hand
maybe you get some kind of i'm not sure
i'm not sure uh well let me play this
move first king
here and after g4 well
i don't know uh i'm not sure
uh h7h6 okay now i'm coming up
to jennifer's suggestion of castle's
queen side i want to have my
king on that side when you do play
this maneuver yeah i'm thinking that
if you really want to punish black
somehow for
having compromised his king position
then castles was the move uh by the way
igor
numikov he actually just played h3
rather
early like and quickly and
uh h3 we did see the capture
queen takes and we also saw this check
again
i wasn't really thrilled as white in
terms of allowing this check because
it's just like
uh uh i was just a move away from
castling or doing something
i don't like backing up with a minor
piece like
why should black be unhappy about this
but if you can move out of check why
can't white move out of check
how so so like say king here
king king could go either to f1
with the idea of going to age two or or
king to d2 with the immediate idea
but he's you know he's not a speculative
player it's really
funny to see he's not a speculative
player he's not playing for like these
wild
you know your queen shows up and
threatens things like this one
you know even if king c2 is any good and
you're he's daring you to take his pawn
no no no bishop e2 let's play slowly
let's castle on the next move put a work
on e1 we got a tempo
on your d5 pawn and play solidly you get
inside the mind of
novikov queen side castling was not on
it in the cards
pawn storms and all that let's first
find out
everything is solid safe
protected and then we go for it
all right well you mentioned earlier
yeah that
he offered draws but i think in the last
game yesterday he was the one who was
offered a drama
that's right and he spent a long long
time
in fact um considering uh
whether not to accept in fact he
thought for such a long time i think he
forced himself to accept it because
uh his clock had almost caught up with
dimitri's
knight b6 uh is igor's choice uh the
knight on these
choices part of me joel's choice
knight on d7 isn't particularly well
placed
but it's not that bad either i'm a
little surprised by that i
i would have i would have thought okay
the king needs attending to
the pawn needs attending two the rooks
need attending two makes a move like
rook e8 this knight may follow its
colleague to the e4 square so
knight be said excuse me knight b6 is
joel's move and
i wouldn't feel particularly comfortable
with my king
on the queen side so i'm expecting like
you said maurice uh
igor to play the ultra solid uh
move rook uh castles with the idea of
rookie one
as you mentioned uh i really feel like
white should have tried to punish black
with castle's queen side but that's my
that's my a belligerent side when you
watch a king on that fade and i would be
going gangbusters
trying to attack but again novikov is
very solid a very solid player
but what do you think about another
position
completely different situation in
yermalinsky
versus wolf there is a roving rook
on b2 in this game
and uh it looks like it's about to get
clipped from the board
wolf simply captured on b2
when he had the chance and let's
continue from where we were after this
trade bishop d5
enterprisingly knight c6 rook to b8
he said i dare you to take my pawn
said white i double dare you to take my
pawn bishop f4 and patrick said
go ahead okay shut the door on me if you
will
i'm going to trust my counter play it's
not every day you can play bishop c6 or
bishop d6
to double pawns this way these two
nights was a choice
by white a moment ago but instead bishop
back to b3
and then queen c1
that rook is off the board we can count
on that but black is counting on getting
a second pawn
for an exchange sack that he'll do on b3
but does he really get it back
as a7 is hanging as well
so i'm thinking rook b3 pawn takes and
then a knight takes on d4
but oh he does get it back because after
knight takes before you have to take
this knight
you don't really have a choice and if
because of the hit on f3 and if you do
then the bishop takes
what's this about still looks good for
yermo if you ask me i'm not a big fan
of black structure yes you're right you
have two pawns but
it's a very different
han complex so let's say i would play a
move like bishop e
three here inviting a queen trick
party inviting a bishop tray followed by
inviting a queen trade uh all on
e3 it feels like
white's for choice i don't know if you
even after 86
even after 86 something under that i
just want to see what it looks like
oh this that that's it
just takes i don't like trading queens
when you have a rook on the board
but i'm just wondering what the setup
looks like like what it what is the
biggest danger for black that c7 pawn
could become tender but the the white
knight
strangely has no easy future
uh we do see the rook the exchange sack
and we'll see the knight wants to go to
c5 as you pointed out
we've seen rook takes b3 let me just go
back to the current
position so we have a b three knight d4
on the board
and i'm expecting knight takes d4 uh
the whole of what's happening all of
it's happening the one thing i would be
reluctant to do as white
is to give black just the two bishops to
give him
the two bishops against a rook and
knight even though i'm
doubling up the pawns i feel like a
position
like this is adequate compensation
uh just these bishops the ferocity of
the open
the bishops in the open position is too
great
i am not a fan of this move and that was
why
i was thinking bishop e3 was the more
pragmatic uh choice i don't see a choice
that bishop takes on e3 if you retreat
the bishop
you drop the a7 pawn and i'm looking for
some kind of other compensation
somewhere
you want to go to b6 interesting yes yes
i i didn't want to play c5 for example
sorry with the bishops
i didn't want to play this this i felt
would i i'd be compromising my structure
a little bit too much
but this sequence with the bishop on b6
well
okay this feels like full
compensation for the exchange i mean i
do have the open a file for the moment
but i could probably just get myself
kicked right back
um well anyway we'll keep an eye on this
let's continue our
our walker a stroll around the stages
virtual stroll
alexander shabalov and i've gotta we
we've gotta be sure to ask shabby about
his
masseuse uh jacket vest that looked very
interesting i'm in the market
uh let's take a look shabala versus
golden from
the get-go as we have in english
transposed into queen's gambit decline
transposed into
already wow bishop e5
okay intriguing
stuff going on here as this knight
man it went from b1 to f5
that was quite a maneuver and
we're up to date with the players after
this move d3 d4
i think this is an excellent decision
uh especially with the pawn on a3
the reason is is because after lots of
trades on d4
often times this pawn on a3 ends up as a
target
and if you don't take on d4 well black
is very quick to play rook e8
and bishop f8 so i feel that black has
already equalized although the jury is
actually still out
by the way when i say that novikov plays
solid positional chess
you're not kidding me i mean seriously
i've known him for years and years in
this position here while we're busy
and jen and i you can tell our
personalities okay should we castle
queenside and just kill this guy i mean
what is he doing putting his thing on
their feet
he played the most ultra solid moves and
then played a3 because
hey if i castle kingside he might play
queen b4 and steal a pawn
yes would you have been thinking about
playing queen b4 and stealing upon
if white had castled in that position
yes i would have been thinking about it
i probably would not have done it but i
would have been thinking about it
but igor whether he saw a ghost or not
he just said
um i'm gonna stop
any play and i think by
by playing it so softly like close to
the vest
he's really letting black off the hook i
mean uh
joel is not being punished for his king
on f8
contrarily if the rook was on f8 i would
already be
arguing that black has the advantage
right exactly
so i'm sitting there saying and
what i i i'm unhappy about the knight
coming to d2
so i can't castle i i'm not a big fan
of giving this knight this beautiful
centralized square but maybe this is the
direction that
igor has to go because he could easily
if you play a move like rook c2 g6
castles king g7 not to mention that
knight c3 might be disrupting
i already feel like i prefer black's
position
i like this knight on e4 so
i'm not a big fan of these quiet moves
that
igor has concocted uh rook c1a3
and so forth bishop we once had a bishop
beautifully
placed on d3 remember those days way
back in the days of move eight when you
had an
aggressive bishop on d3 and now it's
wondering
why what did it do to be punished to
find massivity on the e2 square
uh castles to have this position
and not play at least kingside castle or
maybe if you want to be hyper aggressive
queen side castle which would have been
my choice no question
but this what he did with h3 and bishop
h3 let the guy trade off his bishop
which is not the greatest bishop in the
world
and then queen check drop your bishop
back and then play moves like a3 and
i mean he hasn't played knight takes e4
yet but you can't even castle right now
because of knight d2
no choice it's not it's not going
very well for igor at the moment things
are
sure turning up roses for joel though
let's just jump to our fifth and final
game we haven't
given larry or dima any love let's uh
take a look at what happened larry white
opened with d419 maybe he's being
inspired by
shelby uh as uh
knight c3 is being seen on the number of
boards i must say
i never understood this i really never
understood this
h7h6 attacking the bishop putting the
question to the bishop
the bishop returns to f4 and
literally the argument the logic that
white is using is the pawn on h6 is
worse than on h7
and i just like no he will never
convince
me from a starting position that the
pawn is worse on h6 than
h7 just as you won't convince me that
the pawn is worse
on a6 than a7 so i really don't
understand why why when white does this
and drops back i just think
oh great uh you've helped me make love
for my king because most of the time i'm
going to go kingside
we have a repetition happening by the
way right now in a big game
as far as the future results are
concerned shelby
once again saying i can hang with these
guys he looks like
it looks like that's going to end any
moment in a draw
as gregory has accepted that he's got
nothing with black
too much pressure with the wide pieces
and we're seeing a clear repetition
and the game has concluded just now a
draw
gregory's chances of winning this
tournament fading
with the drawn result yeah
and another great result by shelby wow i
was
i was talking to my dad who is a fide
master of course
yasser and maurice you know him well and
he was like
he's the uh the every man of the
tournament it's like
people who are fans or masters watching
this or just like yeah it's like the
dream come true
not just for the kids but for people
who've been around a little while they
can get in here right
inspiring incredible
incredible results honestly any one of
us
playing with these greats has shelby's
score right now
a win against patrick wolf a number of
draws that he's had in this event
drawing now against kaidana a lot of
them say yeah i'm having a decent
tournament
i'm doing well i may not i mean i won't
win the tournament but
i'm in there with this with a shout he's
not
he's not losing with only a point out of
seven
he's up there right imagine if he were
rated then he'd really be
like you know rocketing up the uh the
rating charts i mean like
or feed a rated maybe even the running
for an i am norm if you got this in an
over-the-board tournament right
that's interest can you make norms in
national events don't you have to play
against foreign
whether the us senior championships
would qualify is another question but
yeah definitely like in the u.s
championship or the us women's
championship there's an exception
okay okay ahead of larry christensen
right now in the tournament as we speak
may i say that
larry christiansen i mean he is doing
well
and by the way let's also remind
everybody the
shall be opening or the gets opening a3
was played in this game against
gregory kaidanov and he managed to get a
slight edge
and draw from a position of strength
with that move
not bad uh just turning to the game of
larry christensen for a second it
looks like uh unfortunately another
tepid affair
uh larry you know has a very very
deserved reputation
as a tactical uh
hitter and he loves to mix it up
tactically but
it looks like he's just spellbound in
some kind of uh
strategical game here the only thing i'm
seeing is
four bishops like four bishops rooks
queens
uh not a lot of excitement going on here
and i think
dimitri actually has a pretty good
position
i don't see anything wrong with his
position he's about to play the move
f7 f5 followed by dropping his bishop
back to f6 this bishop will land on the
d5 square where
it will look like a big pawn but
it's it's in the center of the board
versus this bishop on e2
so i'm thinking that this is actually
not going anywhere
for uh larry uh the white pieces have
been neutralized here
jump back to igor and joel benjamin joel
has been putting on a bit of an
in-game clinic in day two he actually
lost a game where he stood better
against dimitri and then he won
two very nice endings and here he
already looks
like well he's better this king
is not unhappy to
go to the center of the board king e7
king d6
connecting the rooks the knight is going
to go to d5 the pawn is going to go
to f5 and the pawn is going to go to g5
if
igor isn't careful so i already see
easier play for joel
uh now having said that maybe rook c5
can neutralize black's advantage but
let's get active right away with the
idea like
it's 95 bishop c4 that kind of thing
right right i was thinking that before
you have time to set up your one of your
cruel um fortresses
setups yeah just before
uh black gets to do something
ultra good we get something like this
where white
is probably okay in these rook endings
um but in any case uh joel
you know he came in today a half point
ahead jennifer
a draw against his near nearest rival
not not a bad especially with black too
not a bad result
it wouldn't be bad and it hasn't been
drawn yet and remember novakov
is a very solid player and right now
you're prescribing
um you know activity to try to
neutralize benjamin's
positional advantage and he's not doing
it and he's down four minutes on the
clock
because he's been pretty fast during
this tournament joel's been pretty slow
so i think that everything right now
favors joel
um a little bit will be enough to win
that's an entirely different question
but
man that d5 square looks juicy exactly
well let's occupy it
and attack a pawn and after move like
f3 let's connect the rooks and if you
play bishop c4 right
oh wait a minute that's a good point
sorry
i haven't gotten an f5 yet i was about
to say rook comes here
and you're ready to recapture on d5 with
the rook but there is a
problem that um the
rook goes to e1 and the pawn goes to f3
so okay so i have to do i have to be a
little bit more
cagey in my approach
time to play bishop d5 rook d5 and then
i'm attacking your
your pawn on d4 right
so yeah
by by the way if i may the game of the
most interesting game of the round to me
this is the most important game of the
round no question about it
but the most interesting game of the
round is that game between yermo and
patrick
and patrick played a very beautiful move
bishop well a very interesting move one
of those one of those moves you see you
go
hmm wait a minute now instead of
trading on e3 he dropped his bishop back
and allowed a straight capture
of a pawn back on a7 and then played
the quiet looking but definitely
he has dangerous aggressive thoughts on
his mind
queen e6 going to two critical squares
taking on b3 and queen g4
the light squared bishop is the plus in
the position that white does not have
that's the difference that's the
exchange that has been sacrificed they
changed for a pawn
it's that light square bishop that white
cannot oppose so queenie sits
and his opponent guillermo said okay i
see your queen g4 that's more important
let me just play h3 and give up the b3
pawn
that capture of the b3 pawn will lead to
two connected past pawns
two connected past pawns for black they
are way back at home
and there's a long way to temporary with
this
pawns trying to go down the board but
black will have been
threatening the night at the moment
still has the two bishops
what is going on here i mean this
position looks
insane by the way the bishop on e5 also
guarding the h2 square
so no easy king jumping out of the
position that lift is not sufficient
at the moment guys this is this is the
kind of position we like to see at least
i like to see
unbalance chaos wild
in pieces material imbalance all of it
what a great position
and when we're being told that patrick
has been thinking for eight minutes
in this position what after age
and he's still up five minutes no no
he's still up a lot
of minutes on the clock like eight
minutes oh no not anymore okay
i'm sure he's not frozen or his position
margin
margin of error there in his time is he
disconnected
is he is he moving at all i don't see i
don't i think he's thinking
i do see him moving i i mean he's
physically
uh well rocking is not the word but i've
seen
there you go you just saw his hand i
mean queen takes b3 of course is begging
to be played
recapturing the pawn that was just lost
and as you said
you got two pawns and
a bishop as compensation very good
compensation for
rook that and well your mo didn't
understand what what it was all about
uh ready with knight e2 and we
could expect queen d5 lining up
a nice uh formidable battery um
on the uh g2 pawn i wonder what
what long think wrong think but uh
i mean he played what looked like the
natural move yeah the most natural
eight minutes that means he had about 17
minutes on his clock
to 5 49 you know that's what i was
saying about
day one day one i saw this kind of abuse
of the clock if you will
in day two i really felt the players had
really gotten
over the you know and were playing
themselves into the proper form
in rapid chess but what that that that
using a third of your time to play
queen 63 like what i i don't i don't
quite get that
by the way queen d5 was played by
uh patrick's threatening mate in one
and when i see the combination of the
move
h3 and f3
not i i i look askew i mean uh i don't
like
the the you know one of those moves fine
maybe he should have started with f3
back when
when he but now he's played both h3 and
f3
and i prefer black now
uh the point is this bishop on e5 is
actually doing a great job
and the knight just popped in and again
against
h3 and f3 one of this
i'm not going to call it a sin but one
of the
things you really have to worry about is
a knight
landing on h4 so that knight takes g2
as well as knight takes f3 sacrifices
uh can hit you and guillermo says right
i i know what you're talking about
let me stop that knight from ever even
landing there but already i feel like
uh black has uh the better of it
certainly the initiative on his side and
the pawns on c7 and
d7 boy don't let
one of those you say it's so far away
just give them two moves
you're a c5 and a c4 could we could we
just get those two moves then you get c5
and c4
you start saying wait that pawn got i'm
really far really fast
it doesn't take that long for it to
happen and so you do have to be mindful
of
these crazy possibilities that could
happen on the board as the past pawn the
unbalanced position
that said it is an exchange but again in
exchange for two pawns
that means it's not even material
deficit in the normal count
will that rook get any love because it's
not getting to a8
a bishop c6 move even though it blocks
the pawn
on c7 that bishop is
is secure and ensconced on the c6 square
and the bishop on e5 you mentioned yes
that's a great piece
lording over the chessboard in four
different directions
as well i mean just controlling so much
of the board
man you just yeah it may not be better
for black yet
but it's sounding better right the more
you talk about it
now meanwhile we've had a lot of trades
in our critical game not as exciting as
this one i warn you but
um all the pieces have come off the
minor pieces and one pair of ropes
what okay black has this nice work on d5
is this going to fizzle out into a draw
any moment or does
joel have better activity and can play
for something i mean
if i could play for you know playing a5
take some b4 or rook b5 and stick my
king on b5
maybe i have some argument that i'm
going for the w
yeah but that's a lot of people i made
in a row
yes indeed optically it does
appear better for for for white whether
you could get in
just as you said it jen a5 a b rook b5
and king to d5
all before white does something like g4
and also um manages to activate his rook
along the g
file right so in other words but why did
he start with
rook c one probably he's trying to go
rook c5 if you think that might be a
draw but you better be sure
as we've seen before in these usm ninjas
when you offered the end game
and it looks like we had a blunder in
another game with chabot and golden you
want to check it out
sure let's take oh i see a sudden
discovery as
uh we got to this position
talk talk queen g5 my spidey sense is
tingling as i'm looking at that
uh tender g2 pawn shibala thought he had
it all under control played queen f3
and golden said wait a minute but
but hold on i mean h4 is now on the
board
this knight is a hanging on b4 and if
you take the queen pawn takes and then
you have two pieces hanging
and there's a knight d3 and any kind of
bishop g4 bishop e4 is met by knight e7
jack so yeah
yeah that's always disaster got e7 and
two miners all
all under attack way too many threats
wow way too many to brexit
move though h4 nice nice wishes uh
i like that but where do you put oh you
can't you can't play queen d8
because queen g4 ends your life queen g4
or queen g3 either way sorry your knight
is hanging
and there's a mating problem on g7
both tactics will end you but but how
else do you guard against knight e7
where could you put your queen oops
queens
queen d2 is the only other i can't find
a square for the queen guys but then
there's 97 jack awesome
97 could could end but no i really just
want to move my queen and threaten mate
your knight is hanging
and bishop c3 will save the
will save the bishop and your knight's
god that's going to be history
and you're winning a rook on c8 as well
everything i mean there's so many easy
ways to win here
h4 he tried this night before thinking
that he was gaining a tempo
oops and he's done seven seconds on the
clock shabbat
will rise in this position and he's
played queen takes d2 but we've refuted
this
a couple of ways already yeah this looks
like it's going
to be a nice w for shabalov i have to
tell you i love
in between moves to me they're like the
jokes of chass
because you just you know you're you're
going on one
uh one path and then there's this like
this unexpected thing that happens
and you know when you see it it seems so
obvious doesn't it
like you look at it in h4 but when
you're sunk into thought and your queen
is under attack
most people aren't looking at moves like
h4 they're looking at how do i where do
i move my queen now right
and nice nice idea by shavilav and he's
going to earn a victory with us
well that's about to say maybe it was
just a blunder the move knight before
was wrong
of course golden could have
uh made the discovery this way
which would have precipitated at nitrate
and the bishops of opposite color middle
game position
so it looks like knight b4 was the
culprit that just
h4 he's missed h4 completely and qui
takes d2 on the board by the way
i love this it's one of those things
we i've done a dvd on this what grand
masters don't see
is a title one of the volumes and it
talks about discoveries
and the thing about discoveries is that
we
learn in books and you've we've talked
about this on the show
we learn in books that when
there's certain tactics appear on the
board they're virtually
fatal right you look how many discovery
tactics
as a theme or what white plays the move
you do the discovery
and black just says oh i'm dead right or
black does it
the discoveries are so powerful you
don't want to allow a discovery in your
position
and here your discovery 97 yes oh you
could just play
the solid 97. black's like that's not in
the books
yeah that's not the one you see in the
books 97
trade-off nights with check what is that
that's not in the books
night before now we're talking the
threat of knight d3
forking pieces we got mating ideas where
does your queen go
i mean you have where think about it
where does the queen go
where do you put it the nice hanging on
f5 and you have no way
to easily defend it uh of course there's
again knight d3 might show up on the
board at any moment
queen h3 i guess actually was a move
bishop g2
doesn't get the job done uh but knight
d3 still i mean look at these
pyrotechnics as black is playing all
kinds of tactics
that's how you win in the books we got a
result
um larry and um demo have drawn but look
at
benjamin's look at joel benjamin's
position guys is this whole idea that i
was joking about
with yaz about rook v5 king d5 and just
winning your pieces
i didn't think it was going to be that
easy but look at this it looks like it
it
it's here rook b5 is about to be played
and then king d5 and the rook on c4
is actually not very well anchored
unless you can play rook c5 and
transpose them to a drawn
pawning game
mr king appears on c3 if you
if you oh so you can you can finagle
your king over to c3
that's your that to me is your only way
to to get out of
your king's got to get to c3 the king
has got to get to c3
and then pray for the supporting yeah
supporting c
support the the support your local rook
can i move my
maybe i i wiggle my rook over back to a6
and go after your pawns i am
i'm i'm feeling you i'm feeling you
jennifer and he's playing b6
interesting that that's shot the rook
from being able to get around
but the way novikov played this i would
say
almost from move six seven eight
it looks like a man who's content with
another draw and he's only got a minute
and a half left on the clock so he knows
he's in trouble now because he's
normally not in time pressure
he is nervous he's nervous now as joel
has ideas now of playing c5 in certain
positions
and suddenly if if you can't trade into
the rook hand game rook
three could land with a thud
i mean you're better oh my goodness look
at the wolf
guillermo game if you want an imbalance
in material
we left this at a position that made
sense
somewhat queen versus two bishops
and a pawn what
uh something tells me that patrick
overlooked something
and that's what he overlooked rook takes
h5
takes check and it was sort of like uh
oh
rural because mate is coming
down here and over here so
he had to give up his queen
ouch and it's lucky he has
some kinds of fortress like ideas
i mean this bishop is fantastic
it's killing two pawns and
if this pawn was actually on f4
i would probably pronounce draw
here i just don't know how you
how you're supposed to win this yeah
exactly
you're king we're gonna need to get the
king into the game
and the where do i go with the king
this that this one's gonna take some
thought let's just check once again with
the game between
igor and joel uh igor
maybe he's was worried about uh
this rook b5 and king d5 stuff he just
played rooksy too
why can't he now pick up
what you wanted to do yeah and then and
then
and then you're gonna you can't play
rook c4 anymore because king d5 just
wins because you don't have it
i don't understand i don't understand
how he's playing well you're just
you'd be dead there you've got to play
play passively with rook c5
i mean rook b2 by the way rook b5
without capture was played by joel
and now the passive rook b2 on the board
this can't be good
what is going on i don't understand this
this kind of play by novokov this is
going to be the tournament guys
yeah win the win by benjamin draw by
kaidanov
draw by gurevich and who's the last one
patrick patrick's not winning so he he
is best will draw
that will leave those players out of the
tournament completely
they're gonna they're just joel would
have to
collapse like a 100 percent collapse
you joel wins this this is the
tournament
no question five is the idea here i
presume has it been played king d5
king d5 on the board marching forward h4
played
king c4 is meant by rook c2 i was about
to say good point
this is actually not so easy what about
playing for c5
how um your rook's trapped your rook's
trapped on
b5 it turns out yeah
oh rook d2 jack oops yeah and then
there's oh and now that you've put your
hot on h4 it's not as happy yeah
but still this is not easy this end game
is not easy
you know it's ended yeah it's funny
as joel is clearly showing some
disappointment he felt like he had that
and we certainly felt that way too
but this um passive defense was work b2
and work c2
ended up saving the day for igor where
did joe go wrong we'll find out but now
we should
first see how the remain in games in
progress are
we still got your and patrick that's the
only game in progress actually
i am so impressed i'm imp impressed and
depressed by the fact that novikov
is such a solid player he played with
solidity from the very beginning
clearly and it worked out that he played
so passively it looked like joel had
something
like geez you just got away with just
this
this you know soft attitude in that game
that you really had the white pieces
and you would think he was trying to win
i mean castles early in that game just
looks so good
this one on the other hand if we can
just stick with this one
it's impossible to imagine how that king
marches up the board
and even if it does very difficult
to figure out how you win this position
after bishop to f7
the king can now get all the way to
where where
he's trying is uh oh draw greed
yeah all right well fortress
position i guess wow
i thought we were going to see some kind
of study like
zugswongs along the way we didn't get
them
instead we got a draw well a very
eventful round
and i agree a kind of a disappointing
um way of finishing for joel because
he was the one definitely in the
driver's seat in this game uh
yeah gentiles neither had very much time
i should point out i really like this
idea of playing b6 to get in that extra
idea with c5 but you know this type of
finish is exactly why they
complain about how rook and games are
often drawn because you'll find
the precise way white has these
resources
with a lateral checks um those rooks are
just very resourceful
black got everything you could want
active rook
passive rook for white a rook sitting on
b2 that's not what you want
active king better pawn formation
it's almost a sin that it's not a win
and you look at it
he's got all the pluses how can he not
be winning he has
literally everything you would put
i know victor courcho i wrote a book on
rook endings yes sir victor korchner
your
dear departed friend he would be
thinking no this we're playing this for
another hundred moves
you're definitely worse i've got to
figure out how to beat you
great move h4 um i mean i guess maybe
one might say that it's forced
but under pressure like h4 just keeping
that
that pawn protected and all the
variations where you take on c2 and i
take on b4
yeah well anyway that
is good in a way because it's not happy
for joel but it's good for the
tournament drama i really think that if
phil won this game we would be kind of
um saying goodnight to the
first and second i think that this
result of a draw between actual leaders
does keep the rest of the field at bay
that's right
that's right yeah igor angela now um
racing off in their last two rounds as
they'll see who can get the most points
and whether we'll have a playoff for
clear champ
because these two might face each other
again guys if there's a playoff i mean i
can totally see
joel getting you know two draws and
novakov getting one and a half something
like that
joel does play shelby in the last round
though so we know that
he he will try to win that game no doubt
he'd rather
try to win than you know see a playoff
right
especially with game 10 it doesn't seem
like it's his speed literally
it depends on the result of the next
round a lot will depend on the results
of the next round
if he wins the game and novakov
only draws then he walks he comes to
shelby and he says
if three moves in you want to draw let's
finish bye thank you give me the
championship
no reason to risk like this is done i
don't want to lose a game
to the lowest rated player and the guy
ties me
no that's not that's not professional
win the tournament take home the money
you have the title
done deal so a lot depends guys on this
very
next game everything is riding on it
yeah right i mean the penultimate game
that's why we
um always talk about how dramatic it is
because it sets us up
for a sizzling last round although as
maurice points out if joel has a wide
enough margin
it might be all about trying to fizzle
any action out and just clean the title
well we'll find out which way it's gonna
go in just a few minutes as we give you
the penultimate eighth round here at the
us chess championships our
senior event
one of the most exciting things about
this incredible roster of events we have
in october is the u.s senior
championship
this is an event where we have some
absolute legends of the game
joel benjamin larry christensen
alexander shovelup
people who we don't get to call in the
u.s championship
but actually have won so many of these
titles
yes sir the memories oh absolutely well
there's so much
that i'm grateful for to the st louis
chess club
and the senior championship
and the creation of the senior
championship
and the money that is at stake for these
players
i miss them all they are legends as
you're saying
larry kristensen joel benjamin alexir
malinsky the yerminator i mean
uh shabbalov gregory kaidonov and i miss
these players and uh missing
facing them and playing against them and
i have so many great stories from
olympiads and us championships
and now you get to see these legends uh
well duking it out and okay maybe
they've lost a step or two or move or
two
and maybe they don't calculate as well
as they did in their younger days but
they
are as ferocious warriors
as can be maurice you know what that's
all about
i do and you know the names you're
listening are i'm slightly younger than
those players
and i remember coming up and thinking
my goodness these guys are the stars
that i want to be like and then you
finally get to sit down
and play at the board with joel benjamin
i remember
joel you know he's out of new york so
just spanking me
oh my god that's joe benjamin we're
talking about uh
i remember same thing with the
yerminator
the first time we played he just just
given me a
lesson on the board he's just
such a strong player and you know he has
that that voice
as well that that just makes you know
that he's looking down on you like
you're you're nothing look young man
when i finally started being able to
beat those players is when i felt like i
had arrived like that
that is the measuring stick for the peak
of u.s chess
and yes you've you were in that group i
mean you were
you know you were in agreement you and i
never got to play
over the board but you were in that
group of players we looked up to and you
you played with so many of them over
years and years and years i did and
crossing swords
with them was a delight uh and in this
year's
uh us championship i'm delighted that
patrick
wolf is joining the crowd because this
was another
uh player who just we lost he became a
hedge fund manager
very successful in what he did and now
he's got more time on his hands so he's
returning to chess
you know we're all chess players
sometimes you know
things life interferes
and we can't play as much chess as we
want but then suddenly
we get this opportunity and it's great
to look at this year's
uh senior championship and uh i believe
that ben feingold is also getting in
there and
big ben and playing i remember uh
playing
him in us championships like go back to
oh florida and the key west and i think
that was one that your malinsky won but
yeah
seeing these these great legends
crossing swords with one another it
never gets tiring
and again i yeah and again i just want
to say
that they've got that warrior spirit
spirit
you know they you know before the game
they can go
oh i'm so tired oh i don't really feel
like playing
i i i'm no longer at my best
starts the nights come out and i'm
looking forward to a u.s championship
this is going to be excellent i know
it's going to be epic as well
i remember the first u.s women's
championship i won
it was a combined field so the men and
the women played in the same
field and larry christensen was
the u.s champion the year that i won my
first u.s women's championship
and i remember how a year prior i got
very close to winning the title but i
i was edged out by half a point and he
looked at one of my games it was a
dragon
and this great master of attack was like
jen
you played really well but you rushed
the attack and
i that that really stuck with me because
you know larry is such a
crazy attacker if he's telling me that
i'm going too fast with the attack
i had to taper it down and you know next
year i wanted it was with
this legendary attacker i
remember you just what you said
triggered a memory for me
ruth herring uh uscf
president who unfortunately passed away
far too young played in the u.s women's
championship
and she had a as her guest for nearly an
entire summer
a one robert james fisher so bobby
stayed
in her house with peter uh beyonce's her
husband for
a summer and suddenly
bobby found in the closet like all of
her scoresheets
and he just read them went through them
and ruth was like horrified oh my god
bobby fischer is studying my games
trying to take away her score sheets and
bobby
says your problem ruth is
that you're playing too timidly
you got to get out there and throw the
patties and i just thought
that was hilarious and these senior
championships
hold your hat this is going to be fun
so
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020
senior championship where we are just
hours away from crowning a champion
who will it be what it looks like it
will be one of these two legends
grandmaster joel benjamin already with
five points or will it be
igor novokov with four and a half he's a
half point behind with two rounds to go
so
he's gonna be looking to win in this
penultimate round
if he wants a good chance to get it done
um but
yes it'll be a battle to the last move i
think absolutely let's take a look at
the
pairings for this penultimate round um
again oh sorry the road ahead well
here's a road ahead for grandmaster joel
benjamin he's playing the white pieces
against larry christensen
and then he follows it up with black
against shelby getz
uh could what point might be enough
for fear victory um almost definitely
for a playoff
but one and a half will definitely seal
the event or the very worst to play off
well clearly one point one point is
probably a done deal that's
no question to me and especially since
his opponent
novakov is playing against these two
illustrious players
gir malinsky and wolfe who just played
to a draw
very very entertaining fascinating draw
for sure i don't know igor hasn't won a
game in
the last four games he won on the first
day his two games but he's drawn the
last four
in a row so will he
bring the heat in these last two
he's up against it and of course joel he
doesn't really know larry very well i
think they played once or twice
that was a joke joel and larry how many
games would you give on the over and
under there
yes sir well easily 30 games probably a
lot more
oh yeah yeah easily i thinking
that joe's played like 26. u.s
championships 26 u.s championships
alone and larry's 25
years so that means they must have
played each other at least 25 times in
the championships alone
and that's not including all the other
events they could have faced off and
although
there were a couple of championships
that were paired as swisses
so maybe they didn't face off every
single event but the large majority were
closed tournaments just like this one
right now i'm betting over 30.
i'm taking the bet on over 30. i think
you gotta go forward
over 35 or over 40 for a bet but
let's take a look at the rest of october
well we've got the us women's
championship that's going to start on
october 21st big title there up for
grabs the u.s women's championship title
and we've got a star center field one
would have no doubt that's about that
russian zatanski and yip are capturing
seeds but tata barbara hamian great
rapid and blitz player right behind and
of course
our defending champion jennifer yu am i
counting seven teams in this group
seven of them yeah that sounds right um
one yeah uh eswara and for some reason
didn't play the u.s junior girls but i
believe she maybe she's 20
20 years old maybe she'd she just missed
the age cut off and that's why
but six of these players played the us
junior girl
exactly they did and dorsa derek shawnee
i mean she's not exactly
a old veteran or anything like that i
mean she's
clearly also quite young still in
college there at slu
so we've got a very sprightly group
of us women's players well i'm not sure
it's getting younger
because a lot of the same people are
playing that were playing like three
years ago except now they're three years
older right like genu
annie and um chris have been playing for
many years like four years i think
crazy to be a vet off of a u.s women's
championship
and you're still in high school i know
that's amazing that's just wild and that
of course is a 12 player
field uh which two more players than
we've been seeing in these three
uh tournaments that we've called so far
jen
that's right that's right that will be
four days and so the last day would be
just
two games plus the potential playoffs so
the format's going to be a little bit
different for that one
but hey i mean i can't wait for that one
to get started
for us for us as a trio these three
events that we've just called it the
first time we've ever
done so well i didn't even call the
first event uh alejandro
sorry christian uh was the one who
called it
but the three of us have never called
the u.s junior and u.s
senior no the two we're usually calling
are the ones that are coming up and
we always have something blast calling
these i mean just
so much fun and they're usually
simultaneous as well
not yeah but i'm actually excited i mean
obviously i'd love to be in person but i
i do like the uh the fact that we get to
give sole attention
to those events and by the way i mean i
am so honored to call the junior closed
and
especially the senior clothes with all
these legends and
the junior girls honestly the reason we
don't usually call those events for
speaking for me personally is usually i
can't make july because
the world series of poker is going on um
but when i found out we were gonna get
the opportunity to call these events i
was
i was very excited because i i love
seeing
the juniors um as they are you know the
future of chats
literally and then these legends and the
seniors that
you know 10 years ago would have a good
chance of getting in the u.s
championship
have kind of been edged out by our
incredible talent
that's coming up so i missed them i
really miss them and here they are
yeah well jeffrey jeans and sam savions
of the world
are making seats at the table for
themselves and as you say bumping up the
legends
and we have a book from dr jeannie
singfield learn to read and write
chess now in eight languages and it's
available for free on the st louis chess
club website
so um definitely a lot of people are
asking me
about how to get their kids into chess
or spending more time
indoors and perhaps even more as the
winter approaches
and they want to know how to get started
and hey it's really important to know
the test location because that allows
you the power
to write about your own games write them
down and also to read chess books
and to understand when you're watching
commentary like
this this very show by the way
i was told just got a message from
ed gonzalez our crack uh
what's what a reporter i guess is the
word i'm looking for
he's a guru the word i would say is a
guru he knows
more about the u.s championship than
anyone that's i'll take that bet
you against him anybody against ed
gonzalez
and he has noted that these two
competitors
have played each other 20 times
in the u.s championship alone in
classical chess
it's like this will be the 21st time and
that means that the two of them have
played each other
more than any duo in the history
of the u.s championship this year we're
seeing
these veterans of u.s championships past
actually
he's talking about the u.s championship
not about the senior championship so
this is not going to be time number 21
he's
i think he's only talking about the u.s
championship not the seniors
so uh 20 times that's a record that will
probably hold up
i don't know about you guys i'm i'm not
seeing who
nakamura kamsky no abiana
bobby bobby just got on the scene maybe
family would be a wrestling
will be around around decades
yeah i think irina versana or reuniverse
tatev
i mean oh the u.s women's definitely
that sounds like
that sounds like a big number as well
but
i don't think it's approaching i think
it might be approaching 20 but i think
it really is versus since she's 14 right
or 13 maybe 13
she won with that 14. she was 14 but she
but she didn't play in all of them after
that yeah she didn't play in all the
moments she played one when she was even
younger when she was 12. so she played
one that she didn't win
um 12 so 14 up till now
wow yeah she's playing in about 20 i
think you think so i think she played in
all of them
he didn't play in all of them but she
started in the one that she won in 1998
so that's you know 22 years
and how many 23 and how many of
how many of them did she playing she
probably missed only a few i think she
only missed a few
i'm curious to know the answers to that
question as well what her record is
maybe 18 or 19. but the thing is she
needs to wait a few more years because
anna
and tata didn't start playing until a
little bit later
so yeah for that match-up well we're
seeing one here
these players have played each other
they also played in the senior
championships
as well right they played last year
and of course this year now that's right
so their number
is way up there you could do a probably
do an easy database search and find
how many times they played each other
well i'm not so sure the databases are a
good
source in their particular case as after
all the databases came in late and these
two players
played in lots of swiss events from
world opens to new york opens
and a lot of those swiss tournaments
they didn't collect the score sheets
they didn't input the games
right so they they're just because
you've got a
big collection of uh database games
between these two
doesn't mean necessarily that you've got
all of their games and they are
off as joel benjamin opens up one e2 e4
no fussing around with a283
getting down to business and larry
had played uh larry played the perk
defense
in one game he played the philidor
defense
in another game and now he's
on a sicilian and are we going to see a
rosso limo
almost certainly we'll see bishop b5 i
think
joel is actually quite uh
well-versed on the wrestling law
yes and
let's take a look at
let's take a look at the game between um
joel and let's go back to the game with
um alex and ewar
okay and knight f3
d5 on the board igor black
for this game where he just kind of
wants to keep
pace uh with joel
um does igor i mean he's like
you know anything to keep pressure on
his rival knight c6
um these lines well
they're tepid but okay
after takes and bishop b5 i've always
felt that
white was the one with the wit with a
little bit of
a pull let's see if alex feels the same
way he did capture
on d5 it takes and bishop b5 was always
my treatment
in this position
and i just got to check back in with
between joel and larry
nothing happened after knight c6 joel's
just
tanking uh quite a bit of a surprise
gives us a check and he did play
c2 c3 so got that one wrong the moment i
make it
in a declaration you know bishop e5 he's
going to do it he goes c2 c3 i
like this line also because it cuts out
some of the more dangerous lines in the
c3 sicilian
um with the quicker knight f6
right that one's kind of annoying and so
uh you get this uh this other i mean
this line's fine for black also
but he avoids certain lines in the these
three sicilian by playing with this move
warner
uh white does with by including knight
f3 and knight c6 gen
yeah you're saying that if white played
c2 on c3
c2 c3 on move two he's
uh allowing black an awkward option of
knight f6
yeah well knight f6 is probably the most
theoretically
uh favorable one i mean d5 is pretty
good too
but definitely like knight f6 is is a
big move
that um when you put the knight on c6 it
it gives you slightly fewer options
right
and so i see a lot i see this repertoire
rather commonly actually that people
don't play the c3 and move two but
against knight c6 they play it now part
of that
is because they want to avoid especially
part of that is more more fear than like
an actual
you know specific move order idea right
and here we see joe playing knight a3
the idea behind knight
a3 is that sometimes you'd like to play
bishop c4 which does gain a tempo
other times for example like a move
order like this
sometimes you don't want to be left with
an isolated queen pawn
in the center of the board so you want
to play knight to b5
threatening a fork on c7 and
allowing yourself the opportunity
recapture on d4 with the knight
so knight a3 uh the most tricky
uh move order in my view
and let me just i have to take a look at
mr
uh entertainment shelby gets his game as
he's playing against demetri gurvich
and let's see what specialty he's
brought for us today
okay another chicorin and a repeat of an
earlier game i think irmo played g3
and it was just a total failure uh
as shelby actually got an advantage with
black in very short move order
but this time dimitri said i've seen you
play this variation again
before let me play e3 and e4
and game a tempo
over your game with um
your mo and that's what we have on the
board
and this looks like a prelude to a
piece no f3
f3 is probably far too dangerous for
white
so f3 or no i'm
i'm thinking that it's something like
this could be a
real problem but uh so many
possibilities
yeah even queen h4 right away
check is annoying you don't want to play
bishop f2
and walk into knight takes f3 oops
that's that's too ugly for words could
be another
a a win in in 12 moves uh
and dimitri taking some time on his
clock
what could he be thinking about queen a4
check
how about how about that as a move queen
a4 check
oh sorry there's bishop d7 i like that
queen c4 allows blue by the way he's
played queen d2
so none of the other looks like a decent
move
you're getting out of the pin and you're
threatening to capture
if if you can get your opponent
to capture on e2 this you definitely got
something to work with
as white thanks to the two bishops and
uh pretty good development just count
them
four units in the field of battle versus
two
so development edge and the two bishops
by the way
says that queen d3 was a big advantage
for white which
i'm not sure why but maybe it has
something to do with the fact that that
b5 square if you ever take move your
knight away is going to be very
appealing
um makes sense to me variation though
because like if i take on e2 here
with with black well yeah it's the same
same line right yeah i'm still getting
the
the the advantage that i'd i'd love to
have i'd love to have this nice
bishop and i'm also tickling this pawn
and don't forget bishop b5 check
c7 backward palm bishop takes e2
um by shelby after the move queen d2
i can well believe that queen d3 is a
nice little subtlety
um bishop takes e2 on the board i
suspect
knight takes e2 i would want to rid
myself
of this very powerful knight bishop b4
be careful
bishop b4 and then i'd have to go back
right and now now you are
are you threatening are you actually
threatening this pawn
because black could play dynamically in
a position like this one now maybe
sacrifice
this this pawn on d4 in order to get
some
additional play i might even i would
consider knight f6 even though
this does look like a real sacrifice
i don't i get i'm one tempo short of
actually getting my 94 tactic that i
want
surprising for me uh bishop takes e2 by
dimitri he says no i'm satisfied with
the two bishops you may have
a good knight but i like the light
square bishop
maybe this is one of the reasons why var
thought that maybe the queen was better
placed on d3
if the queen were on d3 in this specific
position
we would have castles and queen c4
as a dangerous continuation we have
knight e7
on the board okay
knight e7 and i suspect castles is
coming up shortly
we'll keep an eye on this game gregory
kaidanov versus alexander
shabalov let's take a quick gander at
this one
pre-tournament for a game that might
decide the destiny of the event
not the case but still an interesting
one
yeah i remember i tried this idea of
b7b5 against
rafael vaganyan but rafiq did
definitely did not play knight a3
against me uh bishop a6
well these guys are off at some
completely different
uh area of their chess libraries as
this is almost it's like they're going
for a fischer random position and
randomizing things bishop a6
c2 c3 the natural follow up to one
g3 e6 bishop g2
what is going on
makes sense to me okay uh
somehow i am about to say that i like
white's position somehow i don't know
exactly
how he got a position there is this
pawn on c7 unless shabala
can't i can't uh
why can't he just play c7 c5 if if
if black can get away with c5 without
any
hits he'll be fine perfectly fine
it would even even look logical what
black has been doing while white's
knight on e3 you'd say well what's that
guy yeah
what happened over there and the bishop
on a5 by the way also
and he's played it he's played c5 and
said
what you got yeah you'd almost suggest
for white
why don't you try the move b2b4 to
prevent c5 and you can't i hope
take this pawn because of rook b1 but
after rook c2 we are seeing c5
d takes c5 i suspect
we're about to see knight take c5 and
block it's fine looks like black is fine
yeah continuing our uh look let's take a
look at
patrick wolfe versus alexander golden
what another monstrosity
what has happened here knight
g6 okay white play c2 c3
normal move and d5
i thought eyes were playing tricks on me
because i didn't know i didn't compute
the knight on g6 right away i was like
what
yeah like this is like a position where
you would expect the knight to be on
essex
right but still this looks dodgy to me
something seems smelly very very very
much so indeed i mean
takes let's say queen takes
do we wanted i i mean
usually i don't get such a oh baby queen
d3
oh sorry yes then in that case d4
right i was about to say i usually don't
get such a
clear opportunity to strike against the
f7 pawn
as i'm seeing here but d4
with the idea of bishop b3 i'm actually
turning c4 and d5
also that's a little a little annoying
idea i mean yeah maybe you can
save the loss of a full piece sometimes
with the
b5 but it looks like it's going to be
absolutely terrible for you
wow you could be able to play b5 and i
get my bishop b3 and with the tempo
how sweet is that and you create some
weaknesses on
the a8 you know b7 c6 squares
indeed um this must be some
theory that i have no familiarity with
because it just looks wrong but uh
you know uh prep we oh okay
no this was no okay in fact this is the
position on the board jen
uh patrick hasn't even captured on d5 he
may
he may just think what by d2 d3 one of
the things is uh
uh when these guys and we're seeing it
when they get surprised in the openings
they're really going in the tank
patrick wolf just you know used like 10
of his 15 minutes
and look at this d2d4
immediately okay that i thought you
could play d takes e4
here yeah it looks like a logical move
i mean is he trying to play for d5
immediately no because i think you've
got your b5 uh but
how about this weirdness i don't know
i'm just uh
i'm just trying to guess what i think
might be the prep going on here i i i
could get behind this for patrick
if his if his bishop does land on e4
he'll have a pull
so that was why we've seen d4
wild wild is right at least
insane chest position you don't see
these pawns abreast like this early in
the game very often that's just
let's see uh what has happened in the
game between joel's
benjamin our clear tournament leader
as he looks to try to put his signature
on the 2020 senior championships
bishop g4 and he played
bishop e2 okay knight f6
and d3 i'm not sure i'm a big fan of
this
combination of moves again i'm always
thinking that this knight
is looking to play itself to the d5
square
and i'm thinking that d4 is the move but
okay
joel d3 e6 knight c4
bishop e7 on the board he does have an
opportunity
to snap off this bishop and
why not right what happens after
knight e3 forking the queen and
attacking the bishop
well that's going to be it's going to
get the two bishops in that position
nothing nothing seems
like black and prevented like is
accepting it
nothing to accept it's a done deal right
i mean yeah it's so i mean but
bishop bishop e7 so he could he didn't
have to allow it so he's
he said i'm willing for you to play this
move
i could have done something with my
bishop but i'm going to
allow you to play this move because you
got to be a little careful i mean if you
if you play something like bishop h5
um you know you're you're taking too
many liberties with your king on e8 i
mean queen b3
and you know how exactly are you
defending that pawn queen d7 i have 95
you stick your queen on c7 i played
bishop f4 and i played the c3 sicilian
before myself
it's got a little bit of a punch if you
just sit back there and don't castle
okay um right larry acquiesce to that he
just felt he needed to get his king out
of the
out of the center and and play castles
and at the cost of potentially giving up
that bishop pair which
i think yeah that is good for white and
this is why
joel plays these lines because he
has this repertoire full of
anti-sicilians
and right he knows that he often gets a
good position without studying
40 moves of theory and uh some of that
theory those 40 moves aren't just 40
moves there's so many subplots
uh to those deep night or so i'm just
thinking that uh
if i'm white you know i'm trying to open
up the position for my bishops and just
uh neutralize
uh the game for
plus for white i
i think 93 should give white an
advantage let me just check in on the
game of
your malinsky and igor for a moment
this is uh
your mo didn't go for the bishop b5 line
he just played bishop e2 and d4
playing against the isolated queen pawn
they're catching up with the players a2
a4
huh okay that's quite a move a2
a4 i sub i'm guessing he was
he is concerned enough about bishop b5
just to put the brakes on it
but after a move like a2 a4 uh
usually uh usually in these isolated
queen palm positions i'm finding myself
on both sides fighting for each and
every tempo
and this opportunity to land on e4 so
that i could follow it up with queen f6
it appears to me that
that black is more than okay
like uh i like black's position
after knight e4
a2 a4 that's just a very
curious move for me a2 a4
hmm and i'm expecting knight e4
okay back to uh joel and larry and
nothing much has changed guys no joel's
in the tank here he's considering his
opt-in so 93
um i don't know i retreated the queen to
d7 i didn't know where else to go
i was afraid if i went here
i could easily be putting myself into
some kind of uh
um bad bad
bad place like uh you could just imagine
something
horrible like this happening and i just
end up losing a piece for no
compensation
so that's why what about for white's
point of view is there anything to
playing queen a4
first with the idea of you know
no because i'm queen a4 thinking that
you know we're trying
to be sick so we force you to castle and
then we play 93 next
um it does how does this change
the situation does this yes sir
yes while you ponder dan's question does
this
position reminds you of a c3 sicilian
that
deep blue played against kasparov in
philadelphia
am i yeah but remember yeah it's not
uh yeah they did play a c3 sicilian did
gary
and deep blue by the way jen um larry
joel loved your move queen a4
as he's setting up the trick of knight
b6
that was i thought that was with a d4
though
uh maurice maybe we'll have to look it
up that's why we've got var
we'll put var to work we'll get down to
the bottom of this
uh queen a4 like you said threatening
knight b6 now
you said castles and then knight e4
knight e3 now you add a fork
now you do and if i take
this is different because the a time ago
i had my
queen on d7 and maybe joel was thinking
that
he can steal a smidge of a small
edge like this although with the queen
missing maybe that's not the case
anymore
when the queen was on d1 c2 was
protected
okay i did look it up i just looked it
up and
it it was a c3 sicilian uh but
it was not with knight a3
okay how did it go uh c3d5 uh
maurice uh he got in he got in d4 he got
in d4 eventually and then bishop b4
check happened so
it goes off into a different direction
uh d5 takes queen d5
uh d4 knight f6 knight f3 bishop g4
all that right i did think i did think
it was with
a d4 or not and bishop e2 e6
right and then eventually the knight he
kept the knight back
and the game the game transpired along
these lines h3 bishop h5 castles nice c6
very similar piece construction for
black
except except that joel added this
wrinkle of putting the knight on a3
by the way it's funny because
i watched the movie recently kasparov
versus deep
blue no it was game over the movie game
over with kasparov
uh it was telling the story of
kasparov's loss
to deep blue 1997. in 97 you and i gave
did commentary on that match together
right and
this uh this line
with c3 joel benjamin
actually gave d blue its first victory
against gary right remember when deep
blue
took on b7 and we were all in shock like
how dare you
when gary caspar was attacking you on
one side and you're busy taking pawns on
the other side of the board
and it calculated all of gary's attacks
and they knew that nothing was going to
happen to it
but it was joel benjamin who had
prepared this line against gary
in the c3 and he was working with the
deep blue team
exactly uh ibm and hired
um the spanish grandmaster always slips
my mind uh
miguel aleski's he had a hired miguel
and joel benjamin to
train deep blue and c2c3
uh joel's repertoire and like you say
brought
a deep blue success now we do have queen
h5
on the board and again i was thinking
that when joe
played the move queen a4 he anticipated
this position
and he would have been ready either with
h2h3
and or knight takes g4 but he's actually
pondering his choices here
let us imagine what he's calculating
suppose he plays h2h3
the bishop is definitely not dropping
back
to g from g4 to
f5 so we could anticipate this right
and joel is probably thinking to himself
okay i take
take i don't want to see this queen
landing on d3 when i'm not castled
and something like this and
i wouldn't be satisfied as white in this
position
so the alternative
is to take
on g4 which would be not
a lot right i mean but maybe joel's okay
with that
you know i mean considering the
tournament standing
um maybe he's i mean he's also playing
great in the end game yeah
so yeah he's just not uncomfortable with
this but
what you're saying is that like the two
bishops are not as big of an edge as
they usually would be
because that one on d3
is back and if we move it to d4 it's a
weakness so
it's like either way we're not that
excited exactly if we hit
if we could anticipate d3 d4 and just
the trade of the c5 into d3 pawns
if we could just magically remove both
of those pawns
then the rook would come and the bishop
would come
to e3 and white's
piece play would be rather
obvious conversely with the pawn on d3
black's rooks are going to come to d8
the knight is going to come to d5 and
white's got a
a problem uh liquidating his pawn on d3
so
knight takes g4 after some
thought what is the time can um the
times of the players
they're both taking their time this game
uh 13 minutes for larry
13 and and change 13 and 50 at the
moment and
12 minutes for joel so for
12 moves 11 moves i mean they're playing
a very very slow tempo
of one minute per move
hey could we could we jump over this
game is of significance but there's a
roaring
raging battle going on between kaidanov
and shabbalov
this one we we saw kaidano play these
moves
he put his knight on the a3 square and
now he's got up he played the b4 move to
chase the knight
off of c5 very shortly thereafter the
knight said well
c5 is good but e4 might be better and
after a trade on c8 he played queen
takes
on c8 and then look at this sequence
knight to b5
putting attacking the bishop of course
bishop to e5 again he's pushing black's
pieces
to what looks like even more centralized
squares good squares yeah
he had a point and he played f4 i mean
every move by white aggressive but i'm
not sure if it's helping
his cause in this moment for hitting the
bishop
there's a possibility of a trade on on
d4 forcing knight takes
and an incursion on c3 by the queen
and that would threaten queen e3 check
and some nasties
i'm not sure that bishop of a5 is not
leaving a great impression
in my mind right now and their
weaknesses in the position
if you can get b5 in as white safely
then yes but
without that b5 move isn't black just
gonna stream in grab the c5 with his
rook
white pieces are not saying anything
where are they going
yeah i don't like uh gregory's
approach to this uh opening to begin
with
and i don't know i don't like what he's
doing because
it it appears to me he's forcing his
opponent to play some pretty darn good
moves
knight on e4 looks really good i'm not a
fan never a really big fan of lifting my
kimono and playing a move like f2a4
exposing my king just as you were saying
maurice uh
i even like posting up uh on c4 with the
queen
you said you know double uh bring your
rook to the
c file but here you're looking at a2
you're looking at knight c3 as well as
e2 like when your queen is on c4 and you
go knight c3 you're also threatening
queen takes d4 jack
yauch and queens
um is apparently according to var
winning
right now winning winning that's
powerful i guess after rook f3
maybe winning okay
winning wow that's what var says let's
try to get some insight in that so queen
c3 as you mentioned
queen e3 is a devastating threat so
it looks like your rookie 3 is forced
and then to stop
the check yeah then i was
i to follow up i was going to play queen
b2 but
here i thought the the the variation
starts to get a little murky
that maybe says that the reason is to
play queen c4 rather than queen
b2 and just follow it up with rook c8
and
apparently your work on f3 is actually
suddenly misplaced with all that power
in this event
i like that it's off the back rank
uh there's no rook c1 possible
right deep idea that's
very deep very deep in fact the move
queen c4 by itself could maybe
be met by something like queen d3
directly
so when you play queen c4 yes maybe
there's a queen d3
the point being if you go after this
pawn
the rookie goes to the c file i'm not
sure this is actually
good but let's just go for it you can
play bishop c4 here
and he's playing queen c4 i mean queen
c3 is highly nuanced
yes queen c4 looks really good
but this move and even in that position
you were just looking at yeah
i mean that that could get really
complicated very fast
uh this one rook c1 bishop c4 do i have
a
g4 sighting for starters or maybe i just
i just played the position
again it's like one of those positions
where i feel like you keep
not you but gregory white keeps forcing
black to make good moves right like i
mean
he forced him to post his knight to e4
it kind of
forced him to play bishop e5 takes d4
queen
on the board by the way on the yeah
because well what was he supposed to do
at this position black had a winning
threat black's
threat is simply knight c3 and queen
takes d4 and you can resign
so gregory had to jettison the pawn
uh although i must say uh shibalov
hasn't
captured it right away maybe he's
he has some similar ideas
with knight c3 threatening once again
queen takes d4 maybe knight c3 is a
better move no shibalov just
he did just grab the pawn but i'm sure
knight c3
was interesting as well he played bunch
munch
and they're following our line with
up to rook c1 on the board
and you were suggesting g
well g4 is sharp and maybe doesn't work
but my issue about this position right
now your upper pawn is black
but maybe i don't give you the second
pawn exactly maybe i play a4
instead a4 as a smart move and i have a
two to one
majority the move b5 is coming
eventually
and maybe you start working this for
comp is it
is if you didn't know black was up a
pawn you'd say
white's got some some options here the
two bishops
but and and the majority on the queen
side
but the reality of that bishop sitting
on on c4
it's not going anywhere anytime soon but
then again where are your pieces going
well uh you know uh compensation
sure but uh from shabala's point of view
hey this is the kind of position he
wants to play
this play for him i i think that
gregory is hoping that you know he could
draw it like
for example after a6 i need to
reroute uh my knight on f6
is the wrong piece i need to reroute my
knight i want to go knight to d6
and the other knight to e4 keep b5 under
control
by the way he did not play shabbalev did
not play
uh bishop c4 i guess he's saying i'm not
worried about the rook landing on my
seventh rank and
frankly i would worry about the rook
landing on the seventh ring
why why is he allowing this
what am i missing i must be missing
something
is there your bishop does get trapped on
a5 knight a5 is playable to try to
knight c4 excuse me to attack the bishop
to attack the [ __ ] but knight c6 now
and
thinking about just grabbing a pawn
and no uh gregory by the way
he didn't he didn't go rook c7 he played
a4 by the way the game between patrick
wolf and golden was a draw
well joel benjamin and larry christensen
the character of that game has changed a
little bit as
the two bishops have come off
but yeah this game yeah we looked at
this to me it felt like white
i like that takes on d5 and d4 line that
we looked better
but maybe there was something there this
game
unfortunately it really never got off
the ground let's jump back to the game
of joel and larry and it looks like
we've got a bishops of opposite color
middle game and after castles d4
so what joel is hoping is that there'll
be a trade on d4
and he'll take this knight and there'll
be no knight c2 check
which is why larry dropped back with his
knight
takes and bishops of opposite color
well looks like a draw in
sight actually i don't really see any
problems
here whatsoever for either player as
soon as black plays knight e5 we're
going to have a
bishops of opposite color uh position
did you not they played each other so
many times i know you don't understand
i think they were wary of one another
sorry jen
bishop g5 and bishop takes f6 because
you were talking did you not like that
because you were talking earlier about
how we wanted this
pawn structure where we can make the d4
and the c5 pawn disappear
yes exactly i'm not a fan no definitely
not a fan
of the bishop g5
capturing uh the night um
yeah i i like i would like to have seen
an
a different approach than than this
by white that said i mean black has some
activity
uh you know sure we place bishop on c5
but instead it looks like all the majors
have just come off the board we saw
wholesale trades on d1 oh
yeah this cleaning person has come in
and vacuumed all the pieces off the
board
that's right and you know lately we've
had even more appreciation
for people who do things like cleaning
because it's so
important right now you know we realize
that and
in this case i think joel is also
appreciative for the cleaning
on the board because that'll put him
closer to his goal won't it
i wouldn't say that he was like dying to
get a draw with white in this game i'm
not going to say that but
he's also not disappointed he because
he's got a really good situation
in that last round playing oh yeah the
lowest rate of player in the tournament
who he knows is going to play a3 on mul1
it's basically like a second white that
he's going to get
right after exactly let's check in on
the other tournament uh
well second contender the contender
thank you
contender indeed uh alex is
white against eagle and alex is pressing
here just a second you're most got
your mo managed to get something
did he play 94 after bishop d7 did eagle
b5 eagler wow how could you not play
knight e4 that's a
that's a mystery for me um queen e7
and just a trade of bishops usually
trades are what white is trying to do
whenever he's playing against the
isolated queen pawn
and he are saying no i'm happy trading
well to my eyes i prefer white i think
the knight on c5
is excellent i think the queen on d4
is similarly excellent and i'm thinking
g4 king g2
and white can press for
quite a while forever forever exactly
and we've seen this from novikov i'm
saying he seems to have gone into
some sort of super solid cruise control
since day one
after he made a plus two and
seeing the same yes you said 94 was
dynamic active we
we saw in the previous game against joel
he didn't just seemingly extrude all
active possibilities he seems like he
settled on this
no risk approach it served him well got
him in clear second place
at the moment but you know irmo is going
to be hunting
in this game everybody's thinking i have
no real losing chances
at all right now why shouldn't i be
aggressive in this game and just keep
going for it with moves like as you said
g4 i can see an f4 and they're offing as
well
in the future for white as it doesn't
look like black has any access to the
white position
right so uh indeed after queen d4
let's just put a move or two on the
board uh just for a moment by the way
it's not that
easy for moves to be played and what
you're saying is that this bishop can
come back the pawn can go back to f4 the
bishop will go back to f3
and you'll start uh ideas of queen e5
and f5
definitely an initiative for yurmo and
it may be a slow grind but it's rather
nice
guys no you do
uh we'll sign up we'll sign you up for a
match
uh dimitri versus shelby
and i like white oof right off the bat
this is a
really really nice position why because
in these bishops of opposite color
position
it's all about whose bishop is attacking
uh better and this bishop is rather a
passive one like if you kind of
look at its various uh squares
outside of e3 which you're not getting
to anytime soon
it really doesn't have a good square
whereas from white's point of view
this pawn is gorgeous always menacing
ideas of e6 and f5
the only thing you got to do is get this
knight
you bring this knight to d3 and the
attack plays itself
you could magically put the knight on d3
you get to play f5 you get to go f6
and as shelby will be in deep trouble
oh my gosh that position is just so
sweet
knight blockading on d3 and the light
square bishop everything you pointed out
there is
he it's almost panic button time it's
almost
with the knight a knight lands on d3 and
it's literally
you're gonna die so he needs to figure
out some kind of plan before he plays
joel benjamin
in the last round i'm really intrigued
by our position between kaidanov and
shabalov if you don't mind going to
that one and we see some wild
developments as g4 now on the board
there's a knight
sitting in black's position at sea on
the c6 square
and the pieces and
a black bishop on d3 seems like they
should be trading places no
exactly what are you doing in my camp me
and your camp
i mean what's going on uh i'm liking
black i like the pawn but it's not just
the pawn it's the fact that black
actually controls two very important
squares c4 and e4
and you're right maurice it is a little
bit confounding like
like ha ha what is that knight doing on
c6
um f5 on the board
five okay he came to this one right in
time folks
look at this trying for some kind of
breakup aggression he's not really
threatening anything though
so this is a nice little no i think you
just
i think i just found a way of losing
three more pieces
for life
whoops don't all tactics work
i love how fast you saw it too you're
like god oh bishop takes on
d5 yeah whoops i
i overdid it a little bit just a little
bit
a little bit yeah yeah knight a7 maybe
uh followed by b5 uh
gregory can do some kicking at least
hmm okay let's move f5 uh
i tried rook c8 and uh
uh always remember this because it's
such an important factoid
when your opponent does have the two
bishops
do your best to to deny him one in other
words
trade off one of his bishops and
uh it's always a good rule of thumb
and shabbat says okay let me try to
eliminate
this guy for the moment b5 is no threat
because all that will
mean is an open a file never mind the
fact that b5 is actually
under control but the rook on a8 kind of
dissuades white from playing the move b5
anyway
trades on e6 and what do we
what do we think still a pawn still upon
it's still a pawn and a trade-off bit
traitor for bishops if i'm white
i'm not feeling happy in the slightest
i'm thinking this position is going in
the wrong direction do i get a b5 break
any kind of love there will be my only
hope even though you have the good
bishop
by the way we have the exciting benjamin
versus christensen position
no that one ah
wait a minute my my sarcasm meter has
turned really high
there was no excited guy yeah
we know that's not his excited voice no
no
that's not excitement uh bishop h5 and
i suspect we'll see a a handshake
shortly
in this one uh patrick world versus gold
that was already agreed draw pardon me
and then meanwhile if nova cobb does not
hold against irmo
and joel of course does draw with larry
which we can say is
he'll draw 100 certainty uh
that would mean that joel would go in a
full point ahead if novocopt can't hold
this
so this game is absolutely crucial to
the tournament right now can irmo win
this game
he's got a great position he's got five
extra minutes on the clock
but we know that novokov is very wily in
his defenses
true what to do here
our knight takes traffic
this he's going to try to defend this
position we've seen him defend difficult
positions novikov and he seems to have
decided that this one
maybe he thinks he can put his king on
c6 pretty easily play f6
and just hold this position forever
but no way i just don't believe it i
mean
okay the bishop goes here the bishop
goes to d1
to a4 that means that the king will have
to hover
around c7 right and then the king will
go here
to d4 now the pawn will go to f6 meaning
that my king will be
closed like that this would just be like
absurd if if this was a draw you think
this is
enough to get the job done wow
we'll also add that novakov is down to
220
on his clock so he has to defend a
thankless position
he does five-minute deficit
this this is not going to look good and
with joel drawing his game officially
against larry that game is now over he
will be eyeing this one
saying come on guillermo give me some
love
win this end game you got all the edges
you may not be completely winning for
sure
technically but all the competitive
factors are in
yemen malinsky's favor right now
guaranteeing
joel at least a playoff if he
loses that is novakov loses
joel will be almost uncatchable but also
hugely important that he
uh will will be playing gets as well in
the last game
the lowest rated competition and i'm
just putting some moves on the board to
see exactly
so what i would want to do if i was
white
i is i would want to play g4 f4 and
f5 so let me just play some bad moves
for a moment to show you
what kind of uh
position i'm trying to achieve something
of this nature
and now i want it to be like
like i i want bishop e8 to be
boof well here i'm just taking a pawn so
that means
it's too simple so in fact the bishop
will have to go back
so yes this was the position i wanted
so now i was thinking i would play
this move yeah it does allow
king e8 right yeah what
this no this one yes this one looks
winning
kind of doesn't it i i'm still not sure
though mauricio yeah black has
you know some tricky moves
um it feels like
that like this should be a win but okay
white has to do it in
just a very fine manner let's see let's
see what has happened i'll just
uh flash back and forth and we've got
the position
and maybe okay igor
recognizing that there is a danger there
of his
getting zugs wound he played this very
clever move
bishop d7 and nahumi is 30 seconds left
on the clock guys and
after bishop c2 he's played king to c6
your mod move now
wow that king and pawn where he is just
i mean just in time is he
wow takes takes king back king to d4 can
be five take on d5 take on a4
that looks like i mean taking an a5 it
looks like
that would work out just fine for black
so did not liquidy you played f4
what a move to see pressure too just
22 seconds left on the clock by the way
he's just got to make a move
he's got to hurry up yermo does not have
to rush this
is very astute strategy
g5 i'm gonna be able to make another
pass
passport
whoa i'm not sure g5
no it's just losing isn't it just losing
because eventually i should be able to
get g3 and now
bishop f1 and then g3 h4 why don't you
trade i don't understand why don't you
trade bishops check
trade bishops play g3 and a4 like what
why that winning yeah
yeah there we go g3 h4 we got the
outside past pawn
yep exactly
his king has to attend to the outside
passer and it looks like the game is
over
exactly just use the uh
h pawn as a decoy and now
well just you gotta count it out though
still yeah one two three
six one two three four nine too much
it's not much easy so bishop three
sorry three and five is eight and three
is six so that's a win
yeah so yes he
hasn't taken yet so take first or you
could play bishop a4 same thing right i
mean transpose it
yeah sure either
take something a g5 is a big positional
error isn't it i mean
it is massive you didn't see the tactic
before
you wouldn't allow that i thought f6 was
required
actually if you were going to play g5
you needed f6 as a prelude
to playing g5 and your mohawk has
counted it out
and this is a simple math right now
no question king upon ending resignation
could even be imminent
after this because there's nothing to do
about this plan
just he brought his king to c3 first but
g3
and h4 king d4 that this is over
this is done and this is a huge result
for joel who'll be appointed ahead of
the field guaranteed
at least a tie for first meantime we can
move away from this because
the girvitch and getz look at this
it's over your mouth it is indeed
guillermo did it
with a bit of psy there it looked like
got it done the germinator what a
blunder g5 was a real
mistake in time pressure in that
position
so much pressure to attack defend in 30
seconds
but yes very important for people
watching at home g5
how it allows for that outside past pawn
after you capture it
right now turning our attention to the
game between dimitri
and uh shelby it looks like the beach is
just breaking
through i would have preferred this
night
actually be on any square you know d3 of
course ideal
c4 is fine but a4
i mean you know he's not a part of the
party
uh dimitri's just played the move f5
f6 threatening f7 check
but also uh
queen g6 and that looks curtains body
blow
that's a heavy duty body blow you he's
broken through the attack on one side
while the black queen is sitting on the
other and the bishop he's just played
rook f5
hoping against hope that he survives
this position but
nobody buys it things are hanging
everywhere
this is this is just over i like ideas
of knight take c3
followed by rook d7 could also work with
queen takes c6 uh
picks up a pawn with a massive tempo
against the rook on e8 rook takes f3 is
not what
uh black wants to do so queen takes c6
looks
crushing this is this is definitely
i mean black's position looks like a
mess look at this confirmation it's
bishop on c3
and he's just taking on g7 very casually
decided
not to do anything super complicated in
that position
i you know it's funny i i rejected this
move completely
because i was afraid of queen d5 and i
didn't want to trade queens
until i finally spotted dimitri's idea
which is knight takes e3
a move that i've been resisting but in
this case thanks to
the queen being on d5 it's a winner so
in fact
this looks like a winner too uh queen
take c6 was
was my choice but this looks really good
still uh looks very good for white
even if it weren't winning on the spot
even if it weren't the best move
you know there are certain positions
very hard to defend i mean look at the
formation look at your bishop on c3 this
is just not
you don't moves don't come easily in a
position like this one okay what do i
play next what do i play next
this one is so tricky i'm wondering if
he can somehow
manifest a queen d5
now is that is that possible queen d5
queen g6 and rookie seven
right and the idea is and they're very
very
desirable mate doesn't uh
oh you could just move the camera
king f2 should well king of two bishop
e1
actually it's just unfortunately it's
only one check maurice you don't
have the desired queen e4 d3 check
or pawn to d3 check right oh he played
an even bigger monstrous
move he played his queen to f4 yeah
with with some nasty ideas queen h6
queen f7 queen f eight yes
stop it stop it oh my goodness
too many evil intentions here of both
queen f7 queen f8
you're not block you are blocking those
threats six
queen eight sixes yeah yeah you can you
can just get a couple spike checks in
but
it's not one you get one check in you
get one jay
no you get two check
oh you're right you're right my
apologies well it looks like you just
got
sorry you just gave up his queen on f4 i
think that might have been a mouse that
maybe he's trying to play queen f3 but
regardless
um time is up for shelby and
no it was the only one yes queen c2 king
h3 was the move
queen c2 king h3
you don't play you don't play another
check
that's not a spike check that's that's
not a good chance that's the computer
when it says oh it's maintenance five
and i just have to
make it made in six let's switch over to
the game big big results happening
everywhere
but let's go over to the game between
shabalov and kaidanov
and this one boy gregory has somehow
gotten some counter play
despite being upon down and that pawn on
b6
that's that's a distraction what the
heck is
rook a4 isn't bishop takes no bishop
takes d5
king takes d5 uh bishop takes
d5 or oh sorry h4 was played bishop
takes d5 and knight c3
was an idea i had when i saw the rook
land on a4
but this yes exactly
that was why he why gregory played h4
and now bishop e4 really has my
attention and
it happened by the way i like how that's
like the second time
we need to write a little chapter forks
that don't work
because you can find a great sacrificial
sport
example right look at what they're doing
look at what's happening as shabala
tries to
consolidate after trading off these
pieces king d6 gregory looking for some
kind of play
with the rook to e8 those king side
pawns are vulnerable
this is the moment if he's going to do
it to go after them
and see if he can clip somebody rook g8
hitting the pawn he only has
23 seconds left shabala with 56 and
chabot says you can have the h
pawn but not the g pawn but still more
harassment
rook over to f8 by gregory whoa
i was going to say that h-bond that sure
looked like a tender pawn i mean
you do take the h-bond and then you
quickly follow it up with
h5 i wouldn't think what just happened
knight f4 check
knight f4 check is on the board oh no
i'll turn around
king e7 is met by 95 check oh no
and then you're up uh rook is hanging
oh he blundered upon him plundered with
this movement gregory
spotted it and now gregory can take the
f pawn with
check and where do you go and he can't
go to e7 you'd still lose
with check can't go to e5
cannot believe it i mean essentially
he's he's the one in the driver's seat
let's face it right
uh but this combination of moves g6
rook f8 we had expected rook takes f6 it
may be something
like this so that you can go check and
bring your knight into the game
but what he did was he just missed
or forgot that after king e6 he thought
okay i'm easily winning i'm going to win
this pawn i'll be two pawns up
what no moves that's a one move check to
miss by the way
you wouldn't put your king on e6 if you
thought the guy could play knight f4
chick you're not trying to
drag the knight to f4 with a nuanced
tempo
it's a one move miss in time exactly
well you've said it
so well so many times uh maurice
time pressure makes fools of all of us
and
that was just a bad uh slip by
uh shabalov as failure for your
your nervous system to connect with your
brain i mean we saw with farouja it's
not an age-related thing
i mean without
it really does happen and that's why
players try to stay out of it whenever
they can
but easier said than done when you're
playing against such strong players
exactly and what did those results do
for our standings i mean it sure
sure made joel benjamin happy right
that's right guys i mean
you can win this whole shebang and take
the crown with just a draw and he is
playing against
the lowest rated player in the field who
has been very impressive so far we
should add
feed a master shelby gets who got here
by winning the national senior
tournaments of champions
but uh joel it's all in in his hands if
he can make a draw or win that game
he will win this title and a twelve
thousand dollar prize
novikov and kaidana and gorovich
are all a full point back they need to
win and somehow
hope that benjamin loses and by the way
history in the making ed gonzalez
has told me that based on his research
no one in the history of u.s chess has
ever won the u.s junior the u.s
championship itself and the u.s
senior championship wow joe will become
the first in history
to pull off the trifecta and he's
looking
very very good right now
that that that looks like the odds are
with him what a remarkable thing
patrick wolf and larry christensen
they've won two
u.s junior and u.s and the u.s
championship they've got those two under
their belts but now they're
mathematically eliminated it is now joel
in it's in his pocket he's in the
driver's seat to have
an incredible record that's uh that's a
good one
that's a lot to win at every age i love
it nice
and stay with us to watch history unfold
when we come back with the final round
of the 2020 u.s senior championships
this one was kind of funny because it
was the site
of the world chess championship in 1990
between anatoly karpov and gary kasparov
and i had a friend who was a chess book
publisher
his name was dog darren and dodd was
really on a roll he had been publishing
some
really cool chess books and they were
winners man
and he was so excited but he needed
one writer he was really missing anatoly
karpov
and he had come to me in the lobby and
said yes sir can you please
please please introduce me to anatoly
karpov i'm only going to be here
two days i said no can do
anatoly is in the middle of the world
championship
he would be furious with me if i
interfered and
pulled him aside and got him to talk
about
chess books and that kind of thing he
said oh but yes sir this is so important
to me can't do it can't do it
right on cue into the lobby walks
anatoly karpov
sees me comes straight to me like a bee
line shakes my hand and starts
chit-chatting
like a newborn puppy introduce me
introduce me
so i said oh gosh all right so
this is bob barron and it's all
and people started you know gathering
around because they wanted anatoly
signature
said can you guys walk with us go in the
elevator and walk with us and go up
and tell me what this is all about which
we both did
so we're in the elevator and god is just
as enthusiastic as you can get
and he's giving him book after book look
these are examples of my latest books
and if you write for us we could
translate him from the russian
and he says and this is the most
important book that we've ever published
and the title of the book was how to
beat
a superior opponent up we go
down i come with god and we get into the
lobby and dodd is just like hugging me
you know like that's really great
and i said i can't believe god that you
embarrass me
like you just did god was horrified he
said what did i do
said this is anatoly karpov
and you just gave him a book how to beat
a superior opponent gary
kasparov for the world championship how
can you shame me
like that well donna had no idea
but he just laughed and laughed at that
it was another
another great moment
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons
online from the comfort of their own
home students can enjoy all the benefits
of our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and
miracles occur it's the sound of
personalized healthcare
and active communities it sounds like
life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess hall of fame
in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess hall of fame
mind art experience
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession
isn't a notepad camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it verifying it and
reporting it great journalists work hard
to find the facts
and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted
we work every day to earn your trust
for news turn to st louis public radio
hello and welcome back to the 2020 u.s
senior championship as
joel benjamin towers over the field by a
full
point going into the last round playing
against the underdog
um well you might see him at the bottom
of the cross playable but at fm
shelby has definitely impressed in this
tournament
i mean based on his rating he's
definitely supposed to have fewer than
three points guys so
he might be there at the bottom but in
spirit
he's not that said this is a dream come
true for joel benjamin he's got
destiny in his hands and all he needs is
a draw
against the lowest rated player in the
field but let's let's get
give him his due shelby has definitely
been mr entertainment throughout this
game but joel has played
a champions dream tournament thus far
marie's
absolutely the way he started this
tournament
off with a just a bang winning his first
two games
did have a hiccup in the middle then he
won two more and now today
just saying look i'm feeling really good
about my situation
no way in the world anybody's catching
me if i just keep the solidity
maintain the lead and just ask one more
draw does he have it in his pocket
i think that he would have when he first
saw this
situation he probably said you know i
think it's good that i have the lowest
rated player in the field
in the last round this is from round one
maybe if i can just stay in contention
i'll keep my chances all the way through
boy does he have chances right now
absolutely and i i like
what ed gonzalez had told you there a
trifecta
history in the making as uh joel
obviously
has been the us junior champion as well
as the us champion
can he add the senior title and make a
crown of three championships jen
yeah that's a great great achievement
you know i mean i know that joel
will certainly be excited to hear that
if he hasn't thought about it already
but look at this he's 56 years old and
i mean he's a three-time us chess
champion he's also had
a difficult time this season and you
know um
not able to travel and play in
tournaments which he could come in
person
um and here he is ready to claim this
title
but you know you don't give it to him
until it's
absolutely in the bag and he still has
to play that game against shelby
and by the way do you think shelby if
joel were to offer a draw in an even
position is he going to instantly take
it
i'm not so sure i think he might just
try to keep playing
very very well mike also i'm pretty sure
we could add to joel's uh list of
laurel's
a u.s blitz championship i seem to have
it in my mind
that uh they used to be at the u.s
opens you know uh the side tournaments
right
and it was sort of like blitz chess was
never really supported
as it is today you see a lot of bliss
chess tournaments
with very good prizes including the
world
blitz championship but that wasn't the
case uh
in my time but in any case i do want to
say that during these u.s
opens i have it in my mind that there
was a number of
us blitz championships
and i i i can swear uh that joel won one
of those
if not more in fact i can't imagine
there's not a lot of those titles guys
like yeah
max delugey was also a really big blitz
specialist right oh yeah
and we've i'm looking at i'm looking at
the list now just to see
and i see that he got the u.s junior
championship
in 1980s
this is 40 years later he was junior
champion
in 1980 and 40 years later a chance to
now become the u.s
senior champion and he's got a number of
titles he won the u.s championship again
in 82
he won the u.s open in 85. uh
what what can you say i mean he's just
got so many titles he won the u.s
championship
in 87 for the first time
but and also of course he's
a hall of famer right yeah and i thought
you were going to say he was chess child
editor
don't forget that accomplishment reading
here that he's also the youngest person
ever to be inducted into the u.s into
the world
chess hall of fame oh really
that's quite an honor in 2008
uh at the that's that's pretty young
actually it's a tender age of 44 or 43
or 44
he got inducted into the world chess
hall of fame
many times author has his students
watching no doubt
uh incredibly accomplished so i saw him
drinking coffee out of his dad mug
i'm sure that that brought a great lie
number one dad was certainly the number
one dad in the event
as it looks like he's gonna take it down
nice um well we still have to wait right
because
yeah like if he were to somehow lose
this game one of those players with four
and a half
could win and you know change up destiny
great story if he loses i'll tell you
it's a great story if he wins but what
the story would be if he loses
against the lowest rating of the lowest
rate player in the competition
and then goes on to win the playoffs
that would yeah the excitement would
just build but
certainly this is in his hands right now
a draw and he is
done something no one else in history
has ever done
in usjs okay it looks like
joel is definitely as expected
uh the move one a two a three yes he's
coming out swinging with the move
c seven c five i like playing this guys
i think that you know i i posed you guys
this question like how do you make a3
look stupid and
i feel like the moves he's playing are
brilliantly answering the question
because as soon as you put the bishop on
g7
like the point of a3 is less pertinent
because i'm never going to put a bishop
on b4
um so i i love the way he's playing i
think maurice mentioned that too
that g6 uh or you mentioned b6 but i
also love this idea of the enchanting
the king side bishop
yes absolutely as i was wondering uh i
think it was
move six where c5 uh certainly fine move
no
no no issues with that i was wondering
about you know since this bishop is
harassing me i want to
castle and not lose my uh
h6 bond i was wondering about
chasing this bishop down what's your
guys's impression of this position
huh that's an unusual structure but i
still like black totally
i mean i could be able to get that move
um
f5 in and time it well right
that's a key question if i can you know
get
get everything in i'm really happy like
yeah
interesting getting a lot of weaknesses
it is i don't know
who's going to take those type of risks
because i think that he has other ways
to play the position
and considering the tournament situation
whoa
we've got castles queen spied by shelby
mr entertainment
is back trying to
win the game with some wild opposite
side castling
whoa well i guess he never left
he's not like he's back he's he's been
here throughout
castle's queen side that's definitely
uh saying let's let's go let's mix it up
provocative but what if
i'm sorry jen say that again please oh
suppose castle's queen side and i play
like knight c6
i mean i you know something doesn't look
like she trusts it
you don't sound like you trusted it at
all jed what is he doing
e5 and d4 i mean i'm kind of excited
about the position
sorry uh pawn to e5
pawn to e5 right yeah and then
something similar something seems a
little bit fun
too much fun i don't think he's going to
play this move takes on c5
knight c6 on the board nice
okay yeah i think he's gonna let that
but the problem is
like so what are you gonna do like
knight f3 or something like that but
then i could take one d4
and you have to take back with the pawn
right
you wanted to take back with the pawn
getting the tempo on your h6 pawn
yeah oh f3
what what
what yeah i hear you
that's from the mind of shelby getz no
question about it
he is keeping this one interesting to
say the least
and maybe three i mean
not uh not feeling this one
not the first move that would have come
in my mind maybe not even a second
but he doesn't have a point no knight to
e4
yeah and joel does have to play with
some kind of
elan if you will some verve something
with with an attacking idea because
sharpie's kind of making it clear i want
to play g4 h4
and go let's let's get all that going
as well so you got to play some moves
and and and by the way i don't think
joel's thinking this is going to be an
easy draw anymore
it's not one of those jammies this this
might have joel seeing red
wait wait whatever let me go get him
i get myself all very enthusiastic
forgetting that all i need is a draw to
win the competition i now feel like i
got to punish my opponent for
his bad play f3 knight h5 uh
why aren't we very enthusiastic about
black's position
here i'm with you i like it
uh because if we play a move like
uh bishop g3 we're no longer tickling
this guy
and d4 is genuinely hanging
bishop whoa look at this i mean shelby
was ready for knight h5
yeah and look at his clock look at his
clock what
he's ahead that's crazy he's ahead four
minutes on the clock at the moment
and he's barely used any time 25 minutes
he started with with some increment
eight seconds off that 25 minutes he's
just throwing moves down
move out we've seen him do this before
and upset his opponents by the way
is he trying to pull off another one of
those again
we're certainly trying definitely crying
wow uh bishop e5
now now joel's looking at that and
wondering to himself
who am i up against like who is this guy
i mean like
like i just wanted a nice peaceful
quiet life i'm not bothering anybody i
wanted my name on the
on the winner's check and the guy just
threw down bishop e5 a move that
joe like myself was optically thinking
was impossible you just don't want to
play a move like that but
shelby said no i am going to potentially
lead to a queen trade
and that's that isn't bad news for joel
if he clinches the tournament on win
right because i feel like not at all he
has taken on e5 so my idea is that
after 25 uh you want to play d4
yeah i was also thinking that if you're
bishop e5 queen d4
any queen d5 just trains queens
immediately and if you play knight d5 i
have
bishop e6 and i mean
how are you going to ultimately avoid a
trade of queens here
not i'm not i'm not i i i
actually uh as black i wanted to invite
a trait of queens
with the move d4 and i wanted to do it
on terms where
you would take part of me white would
take on d4
and then at the end of all of those
trades there'd be a rook on d4
and i would play bishop takes e5 and
claim advantage
uh joel said i like your thinking jen
i just i i like an end game please
bishop takes e5
and if we trade queens on d5 that's okay
well certainly is okay this is not
exactly
trying to kill the guy for the way he's
played the game so far
and and it's extremely pragmatic shelby
has been blitzing out all his moves this
is the first time we've seen him go
into a deep think all of one minute
to stop and think about this position
at least he's played a different move
now different we know so can sometimes
be good
but sometimes be not so good if the guy
is prepared in the line
but it doesn't look as though this lends
any blows
for white in this position queen takes
d5
is possible now is this somehow anything
for white
a queen trade is doesn't seem likely
right queen takes knight takes
some kind of something something my
maybe white's bishop would actually get
to sneak out to a very
good diagonal square like
like something like this may look rather
drawn and
probably it is uh where would i want my
bishop i'm not really too sure
maybe i'll start with my knight then and
one of these days to rescue my knight i
will take
this bishop uh this is fine for black
fine for both by the way um varus
nakobian mentioned that instead of
knight eight five which was certainly
tempting that eight just a simple a6
b5 with the idea of b4 remember earlier
i said that
that pawn on a3 doesn't look like a good
mixture with queenside castling right
right you've got a hook over there right
yeah cause it's a nice little hook
normally we would need to play rook v8
to make anything of this but
right right now just b5 before simple
but really annoying looks good
indeed by the way no queen trade yeah
i don't want no stinking draw i i hear
you're the three-time u.s champion i'm
hearing you're going after records
i'm not trading queens you're not
getting a draw today i'm going for
the victory bald play knight takes d5 in
this position
allowing an e6 possibility
and how do you avoid the trait of queens
there
exactly you can't you can't avoid it
anymore knight f6 doesn't work
because bishop takes f6 and you just
lose a piece
so so why this why this
bishop e6 though was joel's choice which
seems like it will also
end up coercing a clean trade sooner or
later absolutely
absolutely well g4 g4
probably not although i'm not sure
it's good for white now that look at it
knight f6 trading
pieces and trying to keep your queens on
in this position is probably
asking for it is why as black will say
please
don't trade queens i don't want a queen
trade anymore now that you've given me
these gorgeous bishops pointed directly
at your weakened king position so
yeah i think i think that that's not
something to do those bishops just make
me smile
maurice i look at those bishops it's
like what a good day and by the way e4
loses to well it doesn't lose but
um bishop d5 and you can't take with the
pawn because bishop f4 so you would you
would have to play queen d5 and then we
get another
queen trade line if we want it by the
way oh
i guess it's forced but no it's not
forced i mean i'm saying like
we could also play queen c7 if we think
it's
it's
better i mean your pieces are all messed
up here a knight f4 coming rook d8
coming
so i'm gonna say joel's not afraid
at all like not even a little bit
there's no part of his body that says oh
my god look at this position i can't
believe it i need a drawer i need to
rush it i need traffic
no yeah i was thinking uh i like my
position
i don't know about you guys i've won a
lot of championships this looks like one
of those that i can handle
i will say though that there is one big
difference here between the last round
and a tournament over the board
feed a rating points are not at stake
feed a rating points are important
because dole wants to you know qualify
for this again not that that's in any
doubt
but you know the world senior
championship
won a couple years in a row just you
know you just want to keep your feed a
point
right so that over the board there's
that little
nudge um is that here maybe
because he just wants to win because
he's a great chess player
but not to the same degree but the fear
factor is what i'm saying
the nervous tension if there's a
position that's wild and crazy you stay
nervous
yeah you are aren't you just looking
with the black pieces
to get a playable position that you can
look at you only need a draw
he didn't try to make a draw it's not
like he tried to force it on shelby
but to be able to just play normal moves
and get a decent position
what move can shelby make to disturb his
equanimity
like not from right now i don't see it
it just looks like there's no move that
some
big time threat that joel will have to
panic
or or worry about the tension building
in a dangerous way
his king is secure as ever shelby's the
one who has to think maybe there might
be an attack on his king
if he's not careful this is exactly what
the doctor ordered
you want to draw this is how you do it i
mean you just play chess you just play
chess and let the rest come
well i was just going to say it's kind
of obvious that white
is trying to equalize right and he's
just playing
absolutely yeah right absolutely why
would love to be able to play two moves
in a row put the knight on c3
himself but right now i i'm
i'm not that great a fan of trading
queens because i
do think actually that uh
white's king is the one under duress and
you know i like what you're saying jen
you know put your rook on d8 put your
knight on f6
and start to menace the white king with
b5
and b4 and when the draw offer comes
i think shelby would say thank you very
much
i'll take that sir i would like
i would like a draw so yeah i see white
as you know hoping to equalize and if
you don't like them
apples also knight f6 isn't bad either
i mean some position like this
also looks at vantage black
again probably knight s6 is knight c3
right which is what he's
hoping for knight c3 here
i was thinking i think your first choice
bishop d5
and he's played it i would not if i had
the white pieces want to face
this last move queen c7 i just simply
would
is the h2 pawn hanging i doubt it
but this this attack that you guys have
delineated
looks so compelling that if i had white
i would just be thinking why did i play
a3 on move one
he did he did it queen c7 yes
i know i mean this is this is it this is
you know i
i actually did predict this um the other
day when i said that joel
was not going to be upset about a3
like he was really going to revel on the
opportunity to prepare for this and he
was going to find a good psychological
uh antidote you know he joel likes weird
things right he like weird transitions
he's the editor he was the editor of
that
hilarious test magazine chest towel so
i think that um some people might be a
little bit uncomfortable
because they're not in their theory
that's not joel he he's excited and you
can see it he's very happy right now
um not only because of the position but
because of his score
and like maurice said he's not nervous
at all no
he's got the advantage and uh
his his rooks are connected uh
white's like two moves from getting his
rooks connected but
no i mean if i'm in white shoes i'm
thinking uh oh i
really messed this up big time and uh
anyone right against yeah it's anyone
anywhere this is not a good position
the pawn on f3 the pawn on e3 they don't
make a good twin
at all they're just so passive the pawn
on a3 could i have that one back
and give me a night move instead put the
knight on c3 right now and make it my
move again
please because that just looks like a
straight tempo loss
king on the wrong side of the board even
although i wouldn't say i'd be happy if
i was on the other side with the queen
bishop lineup
but rook d8 is coming this is much
better for black
this is just you need to start playing
some great defensive moves
because your position's going in the
tank very quickly and you remember the
time edge
that shelby had when he blitzed out all
those moves it was about four years
yes that's evaporated as well exactly
shelby scratching his head right now
saying oh man this didn't work out
i don't want my queen on d5 at all
you don't want to switch your queen and
rook could i have it the other way
around
and then i'll make a move like this yeah
i didn't want to play
knight c3 and simply allow bishop takes
e3
and knight f6 and rook d1 so i'm trying
to move queen c4
c4 for shelby uh with the i
and exactly and i'm i'm saying that the
problem with queen c4
is that uh b5 and oops
that hurt that hurt so even
you know preparing the move knight c3
gets me into trouble
maybe i have to do it in this move order
and just say okay
uh yuck yuck is right i mean
um now i'm just i'm just so much worse
here already
there's nothing i can do really i'm so
upset about this position i want to play
knight g3
right and see if i can pull off a trade
of of
your pawn from mine if you could just be
kind enough
right this this is this is how upset i'd
be in this position maybe i get this
move
and get away with he's played f4
f4 okay that at least doesn't that at
least doesn't allow rook
to go back to to
look to go to d8 on the next move this
might not be a bad idea actually knight
g3 on the next oh you want a sack
oh man you have to stop it
oh well there there is a problem with
the rook on d1 right when your rooks are
connected
uh bishop what was wrong with it joel
didn't joel didn't do it
what no joel did not do it and i
i admit i freely admit i blundered it as
well
what is wrong with bishop takes b2 and
rook was where's the mistake what did he
the queen cannot come back to defense oh
it's a straight tactic
you're absolutely right joel just missed
it he missed it
he missed it he still
has a great position he does he does he
does
but knight g3 is a whole different ball
of wax now knight g3
you get to move your queen to f3 and
he's and he's played it
knight g3 your queen could go to f3 a
bishop potentially go to c4
your bishop could always go to d3 and
put a pawn on c3
the guy stole a move he just stole the
move of course
black is not as bla i mean black is
still better but yeah yeah
yeah hold on what's this queen f3
business all about because
after there's still this uh
ugliness right i don't think we know
very ugly rook d1 queen d1 rook d8
hello again queen back to f3
yeah now i'm just thinking i could play
like queen d7 or something like that
or dc that's right yeah what's the
positive right because
because there's
was joel's choice and then um queen b3
was played
okay sorry about that let me just get so
now the b coupon is covered but
that means have to use your king to take
back on d1
exactly and where is that king gonna go
probably after a trade
i would definitely be capturing no
question about that yeah
definitely asking are you going
kingside or queen side i want to put the
question
to white king don't see what you can
play
bishop d3 by the way i do have the move
c4
so yeah i would like to see the king
king xi1 declare
king c1 okay now and we're seeing this
position
he hasn't made the decision yet and now
he has put his king on c1
knight takes f4 whoa getting
sharp okay if you can't take that you
just lose so we'll take it
check remove the king
don't forget the knight is defend you
have a mating idea
on the back row that could be annoying
well how did
what did ruben find say in such
positions
combinations are as natural do you play
themselves
okay sorry i made a big mistake i made a
big mistake probably new babies
no knight takes a four can be bit by
bishop c4 let's go back
of course right here bishop c4 is of
course the right move
and by the way time is not a factor
anymore at all
as joel as
yeah joe joel's time is the same as
shelby's bishop c4
okay so i won the pawn on f4 for
this guy on f7 let's see
don't i have some nice ds again
don't see them right away
well if nothing else i can play 96
and you do win your pawn back but i will
have a superior
um minor piece
probably well c c three
c three in that position and i i will
count my lucky stars that i still have
my teeth
and we have a result yet yes golden and
kaidanov was it wrong
because we fixated on this game but that
does
knock um kaidana about right
see right my it was my pick
uh gregory started well he gave me hope
but he faded
i thought it was a really good pick to
be honest yes
opted out joel has opted out and take it
on g3
and this and played rook to
d6 he still got some some
evil thoughts no question there's a rook
b6 coming on the next move
is it going to be enough because c3 is
playable
just to blunt that diagonal i'm not a
fan of it i don't like my queen being
disconnected
but the queen could go back to c2
and uh i don't know the game continues
the game does continue your knockout
blow with bishop takes
b2 yes i i wasn't saying black had
a bad position obviously but bishop b2
he walks away with the championship
remember right away and we know when you
miss moves in chess sometimes there's
some
some evil justice in chess that says
sorry
you messed up and now you're going to
lose the game all right actually this is
a
this is a very important psychological
uh thing and unfortunately i victimized
myself a number of times
uh joel played the move bishop g7 so
let's imagine that i
also played the move bishop g7 and my
opponent's thinking thinking thinking
and while my opponent's thinking it
suddenly crosses my mind
oh my goodness i could play bishop takes
b2 check
now i start kicking myself and really
cursing myself in the worst possible way
and it affects me
psychologically going forward it sounded
like man i had the championship in my
hand
what a full i am stop that that is a
really
really negative energy flow you'll
really
hurt yourself and you'll impact
the game hey look just you know
you be glad that you see it now you see
that it's a threat
and just put those types of things
behind you it's all in the past it's all
in the past
look forward to your next move because
we all miss moves and bishop b2 was a
big miss by joel but you know about the
game
and that's where you saw it afterwards
because he didn't
seem like perturb we are referring to
this moment everybody
that uh we do think that bishop b2 and
rook d8 would have clinched the
championship on the spot
and in fact by the way what is the
reason that that tactic
exists well there's a couple of things
the one thing is your development
is poor and your rooks are disconnected
and the second thing is you castle
queenside
which is a lesser move than castling
kingside because your king is closer to
the center and it's vulnerable to chats
like bishop v2 or
bishop g5 in a lot of cases so there's
like some inherent logic that
that tactic exists exactly
yeah and after the play
uh there was all this uh this
uh we saw a line with knight f4 and
bishop c4
but okay uh the players quickly have
reached
this position and we do have c2
3 on the board as
shelby says i've got to stop that bishop
that bishop
is killing me on b2 so c2 c3
forced and now joel has to find the
follow-up the good news
is that the d file
is not plugged up right i mean you can't
just go bishop to d3 anymore
and say the d-file is closed
okay but where's the follow-up for joel
i should also point out
bishop c4 it comes with tempo
and e4 followed by e5
if i could get those three moves if you
could just stay quiet please
for a couple of moves well i get the
free tempo with bishop c4 i'm hoping
i'm hoping but if i could get bishop c4
and
then play e4 e5 you'll say
white's starting to rock
if i could get those moves so joel
right now i said we're not giving white
this kind of play we don't want to turn
the game around and see
flow happen on white side and instead
queen c6
saying you're not gonna ignore the g2
pawn
and even if you get bishop c4 you're not
getting the move e4
either so queen c6 a nice little
prophylaxis against white intended next
to move
great restrictive idea i see your best
move
i'm not threatening necessarily the g2
clearly not throwing the g2 pawn
but i'm preventing you from thinking
about this move
and we have news the arbiters have
informed us
that joel benjamin has offered a draw
and that shelby is now
thinking it over and hey he's the worst
but i think that's of course he is a
position of strength
you know when you have the you know you
have the big knife right you got you got
the sword
and you got the bazooka and you're
staring at your opponent and you say
um uh would you like a draw right
and the guy's looking at his position
and he's thinking um
my position sucks
i'm gonna take the drug i think you know
seconds are ticking off
the minutes are going now i think i
should just
get out of here as quickly as possible
to take the draw before he
he retracts it right exactly exactly
and if golden i mean the nice thing also
is if golden
golden um and kaidan have already drew
so they have you will be um
ninth ninth place so not last
time um i
i remember this from the 80s it was uh
not the british chess magazine you were
talking about chess chao
and humor magazines and there was a
magazine not the british chess magazine
it was the blunder of the year award you
know because in those days
the chess informant offered the game of
the year award
there was the blunder of the year award
and it came from
australia where else and the player said
i offer a draw and the other player said
show me your move first and i'll
consider it
so the guy thought and thought and
sacrificed a rook which
forced mate in five the player resigned
forgetting that he was offered to draw
terrible of the year award
it was very funny great that's a great
um
wait it was actually called not the
british magazine chess magazine yes
that was the name of the magazine not
the british chess magazine it had a
thumbs down
because it was unapproved by the bcf ah
and that was something called kingpin
which is a british humor magazine right
exactly that was also brilliant
brilliant magazine loved it
wow the more he thinks the more likely
the draw will be accepted
exactly the more time you think the more
they're just
you know kind of whoa he moved
what shall we get an fm
hundreds of rating points on under his
illustrious opponent
has said to joel show me
i don't care i'm gonna play this
position
he's been a wild card this tournament
guys and he continues
to regale us with his audacity
now joel is so upset right now
he has just got to you know you know
okay
i you know like i'm not going to go
crazy but
obviously after c4 black is for choice i
mean
excuse me but you know this guy is
hanging
this bishop is not going anywhere and
after a move like e4
e5 uh joel is the one
who's dictating the action but you just
gotta say
shelby you've got yeah you earned our
respect what can we
say i mean this is wonderful i'm feeling
i'm feeling by the way c4 e4 and
with the idea of playing for bishop e2
develop the pieces
why why should i feel like i'm going to
lose
why not play it why not play this
position
between d5 instead of c4 and what's the
the idea is now e4 we slide into the a2
square i like it
so that was very important uh i was
trying to prevent bishop c4 queen d5
definitely prevents bishop c4
as well i love this move and i mean the
thing about queen d5
is that c4 would be a horrible move
because suddenly my bishop on g7 is
unleashed again
and i can't do that no you're not
getting that
no but the question i would
pose is okay you've
you you get your queen to a2
oh i suppose yeah you could you can
check and you can
put your rook on d2 that's devastating
looking
wait wait wait it's not done yet though
f3 at the end he's played e4 he's
allowed
queen a2 oh yeah but it's not
devastating bill maurice
e4 queen a2 bishop e2 if you go
check the rook gets to d2 but only
temporarily
i mean hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on isn't there a sack on c3 can we
go back please let's go back long long
variation wrong variation
exactly we need to on the board now
bishop e2 what if i sack on
c3 here gotcha that by the way
nicely tied because uh e5 i was trying
to shut
down that bishop now bishop takes c3 so
the idea
if i go queen takes whoops i got you
there's your rope this rook is hanging
and
it's speared nicely with the skewer
and if i take with the pawn i take every
one of your pawns
i mean everybody's dropping to start i
got it
i've got at least a draw that way but i
also have money queen e3 and rook d2
looks like money
so does this so does that looks like
money too i mean
yeah so bishop
bishop c3 is a bomb yeah that that
is the bomb okay so where do you put the
bishop
wait you have to put it on e2 if you
don't like where do you put the
if you you got to play i mean you could
play bishop d3
man but then i can just let's see bishop
d3 i can just play c4 right
and the problem is i have to develop the
bishop because
there's a threat of queen a won check
and rook d1
he thought that this was okay and
suddenly joel is smiling
the draw offer that shatters the brain a
little bit this move i think bishop c3
still works here
i think so too i think it's just like
one of those uh works in every
mechanism it still works you just your
bishop may not hang on e2 but
it'll hang on b5 don't worry about it
you will lose it so let's play that line
just to show it
bishop b5 bishop c3 as he's pondering it
anyway
bishop b5 bishop c3 queen takes me no
loses the rook so pawn takes
and the queen check queen b1
by the way here there is a queen takes
b1
and rook b6 that will win the bishop
back so since we know that
we're not going to do that queen takes
b1 and rip b6 and a6
we're just not because we don't have to
uh we're gonna play queen takes c3 and
in a couple of moves after we've taken
all those pawns
if you survive that then we will trade
and play rook b6
so i could play queen a3 check here and
you can't play queen b2 because of the
trade in rook b6
and you'll lose material right
in in each and every case bishop takes
e3
is a winner uh and i don't think joe was
going to miss this one because
it's really been telegraphed
uh for quite some time once you get your
queen into a2
you immediately start looking at these
types of sacrifices
he just totally missed it can he survive
but the thing is it doesn't look like
shelby can stop
going down at least two or three pawns
like it's going to be at least two
bishop e2 bishop takes c3 i don't have
to take it but what's my move
right there's a there's he's played
bishop to the d3 which seems to
we talked about that one c4 i mean i
don't know if
you're because now your bishop c3 move
um the bishop's coming to b1 and
that line i'm not hesitating
what's your move you mean c4 what queen
b1 b1 yes
ah that's a good whoa
whoa hey that's not fair i was supposed
to take all your pawns
yes queen takes b1 bishop takes b1
and no not after we were sacrificing
pieces and winning
yeah exactly we i i've missed queen
think
this is i could play queen b3 guys and
you can't keep chasing me with queen c2
because then i have rook d3
c2 can i play bishop c2 and then
oh and queen b6 and queen b6
the position has been turned around
one that's a crazy maiden one and if you
play if you play rookie one
forget it it's over that's nasty
you build your own wall of death yeah
that's a nice finish
that's a nice feels like white has
checkmated his own queen in that exactly
that's actually very attractive though
no
he has played c form we expect queen bee
woman
well
bishop e2 bishop takes uh c3
as as we've been discussing that's
that's lights out
and he has played queen b1 b1 on the
board joel will not
trade to go into an end game to say yes
i have opposite colored bishops and i'll
likely draw
he will retreat he can smell the victory
now
as white's queen is so horribly placed
and the attack is about to play
itself queen b3 uh we got to say there's
got to be money on this next move guys
he's going to win in style after queen
to b3 and by the way larry christensen
who had such a horrible start just beat
your malinsky
leapfrogging him over the standings and
i think he's going to finish in the
first half of the cross table
and we have seen queen b3 by the way it
looks like a hedgehog in that game
of larry's and ooh that prime square
knight f6 was a winner for
a larry let's quickly jump back to our
game of joe
queen b3 that's the money move that
that that's all she wrote guys left
we just have rook takes d3 that's a
problem that pawn on c4
um protects the queen um and indeed it
does
he's gonna have to try this bishop c2
queen b6 and
that's just but the thing is even if you
play bishop to
e2 oh right how do you respond
to queen b6 yeah you might fight
though that's true no actually queen b6
bishop takes c4
it's got it that might be about just
going back to your bishop c3 stuff
yeah i will go back to the bishop c3
stuff i was just wondering if queen b6
won a piece without any sacrifices
but it doesn't have to bishop to c4
it's kind of surprising it's got to be
winning no how is it
yes it is winning it is winning queen b6
is winning queen b6 bishop c4 queen e3
bishop c3 wins two i'm just checking the
line but queen b6
bishop c4 queen check you must play
king to d2 king to c2 excuse me
queenie for check hitting your bishop
you must play
king b3 rook b6 check and now you resign
i win your bishop anyway it doesn't hide
so both are winning
and you know magnus carlsen says he
likes to attack without sacrificing
this little funny joke you know we
winning without sacrificing that would
be the way
i said i didn't even have to sack
anything to beat you i just
i just put my pieces on dominating
squares and beat you in that line
so that line is very clean as well no
defense
and uh and ver and various wins for
joel but bishop c2 is a nice position
queen b6
bishop c2 queen b6 game over the queen
invades
bishop e2 oh we've been
absolutely played bishop c2 queen b6 is
just
uh czech nate jen you said it like
whoa oh hold on we do have wait a minute
we do have queen eights who are queen
b a1 okay queen a2
well no i mean it is terrible of course
the queen
like check mated alongside the king
but but i didn't think he had to move no
i mean it really looks like he has no
moves either but this moves
this position is awful awful queen b6 on
the board we're expecting now queen a2
boy i mean every time we we we write
shelby off and say you know
okay that's all she wrote we we
discovered that he still has
one hidden idea queen a2
angling uh for queen takes c4 and
getting out of his imprisoned uh queen
and and excuse me but he also has an a4
idea yeah that's why i
yeah i was going to say that if i do
defend with b5
maybe a4 would unlock uh
the prison as well so maybe i should
just go
you know a little bit more positional
with rook c6
and then go just pawn snacking
yeah that just looks too good looks very
very so many guys dropping
yeah they and they drop everybody
yeah the queen a2 is on the board joel
the play as he's uh
as he's looking over his variations i i
wouldn't doubt that a move like queen
f2 followed by rookie two was winning
whoa scintillating sacrifices
back bishop takes c3
this one we were talking about we
totally forgot about joel didn't
as he's found a straightforward
attacking line
nice 83 and rook b6 jack right yes
exactly nicely done joel way to go
that's the move of course that's the
move
that is definitely the mark of a
champion as that looks like
a crowning blow to be sure bishop takes
c3
and again talk about timing right just
before the move e5 could be played that
would shut down
that bishop joel is just on court bishop
takes c3 threatening queen e3 check
followed by rook b6
and d1 trying to
keep the game going we don't believe oh
there's a mate
queen e3 take on yeah just take like
queen d3 and queen e3 take on d1 and
queen d3 wins
nice yeah and then you have point just
one take and then queen d3 check
and that's it that ends the game bishop
c2
and you couldn't play the other move and
joel is just playing it
in straight clockwork fashion beautiful
we will have
a champion for the ages
this is the last game of the us senior
as most of the games are drawn larry did
win and shelby about to give it up now
because of that beautiful geometry look
at those bishops of opposite color
but the entombed queen on a2 spelling
the end
joel is enjoying this moment so much
it's kind of funny you play
a3 to give your queen a square on a2
congratulations uh this one is over
there's nothing to do as mate will be on
the board in two more moves
well he could play king to a1 and try to
make it last a little bit but he's
played bishop c2 gamely
allowing now bishop uh queen to f1 check
and
will he play bishop d1 yeah he did he
did it a lot made on the board
love it checked me giving joel benjamin
the 2020 u.s senior championship in
style
as he gets first place twelve thousand
dollars
and that historic triple crown
the first player ever to win the us
junior the u.s championship
and the u.s senior as maurice said
checks
a game for all ages
to be sustained excellence over the
decades
that is indeed the mark of a champion
and he has shown it here
very impressive big up congratulations
from brooklyn
like a one like one bobby fischer okay
bobby wasn't born in brooklyn but
you know he he learned his chess here
grew up with it as did fabiano caruana
brooklyn could feel a good olympic team
by the way
yeah one for the ages i might say yeah
definitely philadelphian but i did win
my
at least my first us championship while
living in brooklyn
so there's something about it really
he's got it attitude attitude okay
gotta be the shoes uh just going through
the game between
igor and novikov patrick wolf in the
last round apologies to the players as
we
didn't really break away from the game
of joel but it looked like just a
fairly very well played game i think
that
was that the first draw for patrick
wolfe i mean uh
coming coming into today's play you had
that wonderful graphic
um maurice where you showed us how the
players got here right
and it was like patrick wolf had six
decisive games coming in
he proved he had two draws today
so okay okay okay so
he didn't realize that draw is a
respectable result and he got it
and shibalov and dimitri garvich uh also
a game that unfortunately actually
patrick had three drawstrings
yes yes he got
he got what he wished for don't don't
ask for it
it's better to win to lose one and win
two than to draw all three so
so he got the um yes he got the uh even
score
and i i think silver medal is gonna be a
big tie i think
i believe it yeah it looks like it's
gonna be a big tie with
five points i believe so a huge margin
of victory here by joel benjamin look at
him
dominating the field a point and a half
ahead our champion
and a three-way tie for the silver medal
gregory kaidena novika and dmitry
gurevich
nice revolt taught by fema we hadn't
talked about him a lot
but hey he's the only one who could beat
joel so
big uh big nice result for gima as well
larry christensen and patrick wolf
both with even scores but larry's got to
be happy about that because he started
out quite terribly didn't even have a
happiness i did
yeah no the first day was it was really
really bad and
uh good comeback by larry yeah yeah and
then he went plus one on both of the
other days to
bring himself up to that even score yeah
and we have the champ joel benjamin
did it as a junior he did it as an adult
and now the senior champion joel
congratulations on a fantastic
finish thank you so much i think
after this weekend i can say life begins
at 50.
nice did you know that you were angling
for the trifecta was it on your mind
the three championships which one would
you mean junior
right junior right in the u.s
championship and as a senior as well
uh i wasn't really thinking about that i
was thinking more about twelve thousand
dollars
that's going to really come in handy
at age 56. you're the only person in
history to win the three titles though
that must mean something
well the senior championship has been
only been around a couple of years so
somebody else will get it eventually i
think
though i think ed might have been
counting senior open champions too but
we'll have to double check that okay so
okay
but joel you know talk a little bit
about this final round game it was so
entertaining
did you burn the midnight oil to figure
out what to do against 183
well um you know i had looked at it
beforehand and he played this against
novakov and i checked it on the computer
and novokov was just winning the whole
game so
i think it was kind of foolish for him
to play
almost exactly the same thing okay e3 i
guess was new
but you know it was i came in computer
checked so it was easy for me to put
these moves on the board
yeah and i had to find knight h5 and
after that black is a very easy game
yo we hate to put a blemish on the
victory since
you did it in sacrificial style but you
did have a sacrifice
early in the game right here that would
have won
bishop b2 correct
uh yeah it can't yeah yeah i was kind of
uh
i was kind of vaguely aware of that
afterwards um
but i mean i mean i felt his position
was just
it was just so bad and uh he he actually
defended it pretty well
and so it wasn't it wasn't obviously
winning for me so i actually
offered him a draw after queen c6 it was
a gift to be honest
i mean no in any other circumstances i
never would have done it but
you know just to make sure to win the
tournament exactly i wasn't
upset when he said no right
you went on to win in beautiful style he
was still trying to defend
once you got that queen into a2 things
look pretty rosy
yes yes and uh
yeah and then you got a chance to
sacrifice again
the rook coming to the b file necessary
pretty joel with all these tough players
that you've played over the years
to win by a point and a half is not easy
your thoughts about that accomplishment
oh i never would have dreamed uh
to do that i you know last year was a
very
tight tournament and um
but you know i think in you know in in
rapid chess
you have you know more strange things
happening
and it was just that with all the other
players these strange things seemed to
balance out and with me
you know things kept falling my way i
mean
you know the you know i i i like i i
forgot the forgot the move against your
mulinsky and i had horrible position in
no time
and i won that game you know so um
you know a lot of games could have gone
either way and uh fortunately they
now this game i i don't know if i had a
chance to
to win this ending but given the the um
the tournament situation i didn't want
to risk it
yeah that makes a lot of sense the oh i
thought you were talking about the one
against the one again we're talking
about the one novakov yeah
were you surprised he played this
passively against you
because he could have played much more
aggressively in the opening he's not an
aggressive player i think i think that's
i think that's his problem if he if he
you know
played a little bit more courageously i
think he'd be a stronger player
but he tends to make safe decisions
indeed but i was suspicious about my
opening you know i was
uh i was very happy when he i thought
that he should have um
uh after king f8 i thought he should
have just castled
it might move forward a moment i thought
he should just castle king's side here
and if queenie aiko queen d1 that
you know i have some trouble with my
king i think that's what he should have
done
he played a lot of scenes properly here
and that made it easier for me
but did you notice that almost every
game i was playing with a knight against
a bishop
you did manage to do it
but every all the other games and i i
won two two uh night versus bishop
endings in one day
it wasn't by design it's just not that
yeah yeah a lot of minor peace end games
in fact
it it was uh pretty remarkable joel you
have
a a lot of students were many of them
watching rooting you on
and tell us a little bit about the
experience of playing
for the online crowd oh well
i i have no idea what was going on in
terms of
of students but i do i do have to uh
to give a shout out to my boy john burke
i'm you know so proud of him
you know i had a chance to work with him
five or six years and uh i could see he
had talent from the beginning
and to see him win the u.s junior
championship is a huge thrill for me
so i'm very excited about uh about uh
that particular student and i
i see that he's rocking the wild hair
like me you know like the uh
the lockdown hair he's got it going on
you still work with him or you used to
no no i could
you know him and him and brandon and
praveen
i worked with all of them but i call
them my graduates because they don't
need me anymore
they gotta they know what they're doing
were you actually able to watch that
armageddon game joel or was that like
too nerve-wracking
having um you know your favorite in that
in that game
yeah you know i i only watched this
sporadically because i
i was very focused on my own tournament
so i i only heard about the
um the armageddon game uh afterwards
and you know a bit of it's always a bit
of a controversy
when you have an armageddon game because
you know by its very nature it's going
to come out a little unfair that's just
that's just
this is the way it is but here's
something you may not have been aware of
that john had already won a tournament
on an
armageddon game against jeffrey zhang he
won the us masters the same way
we did not know that yeah
but bit of trivia a bit of trivia indeed
well back to you though and here they
are
hollow champion so far is we are going
to crown two more
karissa yet john burke and joel benjamin
are
girls junior junior and senior champion
i'm very nice and but joel uh
one more question for you from me um
this has
obviously been a difficult time for a
lot of people with the
the lockdown and interruptions and
travel and work
tell us a little bit about your
experience and how
um you reflect on winning this event
during this difficult time
yeah well just to frame things the the
last time that i
ate inside a restaurant was on my
birthday this year
in prague it was the day before
uh trump announced all americans got to
come home from europe right now
and everything got crazy so that was
like the last moment of sanity
and then i came home and i i quarantined
for two weeks
and then i got covered anyway but i was
i was very fortunate that i had a very
mild case and my wife my wife as well
i think she gave it to me but my kids
didn't uh suffer any effects at all so
um but now with the with the research
they're saying that it's possible
that you could get it again so it's just
you never
yeah so basically i just i just go and i
buy
groceries and i i stay at home you know
i'm
i'm it's not really how i want to live
but that's
that's that's the situation right now
pretty and yet you're able to play chess
and win a national championship i mean
that's
simply amazing isn't it this is an
incredible thrill for me
i um i'm i'm so grateful
to to the st louis chess club for for
including the seniors you know i've
you know i felt for a long time that we
have an
incredible bunch of really strong
serious players
and that we should have this this
opportunity
but you know they made it happen and uh
it it makes a huge difference in in our
lives it's
it's the the one meaningful opportunity
that
that we have and it's uh it's just a
wonderful thing
well said joel well said and we couldn't
think of a finer champion you've been
representing us chess now
for decades and you are indeed the u.s
senior
champion you can add that to your mantle
of many accomplishments
congratulations on a fabulous
performance and
enjoy the twelve thousand dollars and of
course the title oh
thank you so much congratulations joe
well done
and look at this i mean guys i i won
two in a row i picked burke now i picked
joel benjamin to win it
i mean and you know the other funny
thing about this is that i always went
last i let you guys pick first
then i picked because i didn't want you
guys to copy my bit
you know yes sir i'm hearing some
serious bloating
like trash talking coming
from the normally jennifer shahady boy
she's smacking us down hard right now
and she's such a sweet person too i was
really shocked the way she
the way she insulted carissa she said
that
we have this group of champions
and who will they who will join
uh this group of champions i'm sitting
there saying carissa is trying to win
the women's championship
why beat down on poor carissa jen i
well i mean very stuff
i didn't think about that carissa was
the only one who had the chance to win
two
that is that would be quite remarkable
two out of the five
well he was one of the favorite and who
and who rocked carissa in the first
place jen
oh well yes yes you did
you got that one right i i wasn't i
wasn't involved
i wasn't involved i was i sat that one
out so right
just right i am over two so far i'd
admit that i hand over to i picked
jeffrey in the last
one and shabalov in this one but coming
up roses jen i gotta say
i'm i'm waiting to see you go first next
time
well let's count down our incredible
competitors
in this u.s senior championship shelby
gets he did end up in last place but
wow did he entertain us and this shows
us why
sometimes it's great to have a wild card
in the event in this case it was
the national senior tournament of
champions in orlando last year that got
him in
and we won't be forgetting shelby
anytime soon
thank you shelby you brought the
entertainment
big respect alexander golden
also um getting two thousand dollars for
his ninth place finish
i mean he had one of the best
backgrounds in it and he also won that
extremely entertaining time scramble
against shelby
that was very memorable for me okay
eighth place it's kind of surprising to
see grandmaster alex normalinsky in
eighth for three thousand dollars
because
he seemed to be a factor punching
throughout the event
but um tough finish and i think this is
a tie for eight
so um that's part of the reason as well
and he lost that last game to larry
right that
allowed larry to leapfrog over irmo
alexander shablov seventh place for
three thousand dollars but
as usual sha blob entertained us
throughout this event
absolutely that game that he'd lost to
gregory kaidanoff that had to hurt a lot
larry christiansen he was actually came
in as
the top seed by raiding he ends up tied
for fifth place a disastrous start but
he really recovered to finish in the
middle of the field
in days two and three well done larry
patrick wolf coming out of retirement to
play
the 2020 u.s senior and while he had one
of the
most gorgeous games of the event against
dmitry girvich
ended with fifth place and four thousand
dollars and
wow he did not show that much rust gas
yeah he was all over the place though i
mean those six decisive games out of six
played
and then the finish of three draws in a
row uh
well thank you patrick what can i say uh
nicely done
on your type of fifth yeah if you knew
how to play against the scandinavian you
would have been like second place
seriously speaking of tied for second
place we had
this man grand master you or novikov a
major factor in the event throughout
super solid but unfortunately towards
the end
um lost a critical game and ended up
tied for second um with very little
chance to win first in the final round
six thousand six hundred sixty seven
dollars for his efforts though jim
nice they rounded it up no no
and grandmaster gregory kaidanov
um your pick going in one of them won
one of the most gorgeous games in the
event
in the very first round against patrick
wool and
ended in a pie per second very nice
result
absolutely well done gregory
also tied for a second we have the only
player
to be our champion dmitry girvich
and he will also take home that 6667
prize he had a quiet event
but he was always in the top half of the
field and like you said he
did ding our championship
that's right and you know he was ranked
one of the lower
rated players coming into this so really
well done by nima
but it's all about the benjamins says
grand master joel benjamin won 12 000 of
them
and he also wins this title and that
triple crown
being the first player ever to win the
u.s championship the u.s junior and the
u.s senior
and it was just great to see him smiling
throughout the event i think that's
what makes for longevity you can see
that joel still gets so much joy from
the game
after all these years absolutely well
done sir
and you know we've got some more
championship tests coming to you
as we are following up this 2020 u.s
senior championship with
a day off tomorrow on tuesday and we
come back on wednesday
october 21st to call the u.s women's
championship
and look at this field of competitors
yeah as mentioned yiff
will be going for her second title in
october while perennial favorites crash
into tonski return
rapping and blitz beast tata barbara
kamian and of course our defending
champion
jennifer yu what a cast absolutely 12
play around robin this time not the 10
players
that we've been uh witnessing but 12 of
them count themselves four
days of action coming
after a free day one free day can't wait
and four previous champions in the event
one of them a reigning champion and
jennifer you
we see arena crush of course and anna
zatonski
who won many championships in a row also
sabina foyser
who won a long championship as well so
will it be one of the four who've
already shown that they can get it done
or will it be a new face carissa yip
maybe she just came off the u.s
girls junior this could be a really i
mean he's going to be fighting chess
no matter what that's going that's going
to be a lot of fun to call by the way
one little bit of trivia to add uh ed
gun's office
did his research as well he said arthur
bisguire did win
a couple of u.s junior opens or at least
a
junior u.s junior opening u.s senior
open
joel is the one the only one to win the
invitationals
a little bit more elite events if you
will
those at the top of the cream of the
crop in
those age categories and joel again the
only player in history to get that done
okay thanks for that clarification well
take a day off tomorrow from watching
our coverage of the us championships of
course
you can check out our youtube channel at
the st louis chess club
to watch all the archives if you missed
any of it we also have kosher kavutsuke
who is doing bonus coverage there
so check that out and big thank you to
our team to join antonia at the chess
club to
dr jeannie and rex singfield and to
everybody who makes this production
possible
absolutely big thanks to all of our
technical team
wow you guys do just such an amazing job
and thank you everyone for joining us
we'll see you and
in the days time and uh have a good
night good night everyone good night
everybody
you